- When I landed in San
Francisco, I was like,
"Fuck, this air sucks."
I'm breathing it in, I'm like,
"Oh my God, the pollution."
- How can you tell the pollution levels?
- Well, when you breathe in.
When I land in the fucking
country, I step off the plane,
I take a deep breath.
I'm like, "This air's shit."
(all laugh)
Why is this insane?
- It literally sounds like
the stupidest superpower.
(gentle upbeat music)
- Gentlemen, I have the
intro for this, all right.
- Gentlemen.
- What if I told you,
you could get anime for free?
(Joey laughs)
For free, gentlemen.
- Wait, are we fucking
jumping right into it?
- Because that's gonna be
the first topic for today,
but right now, I have with
me the boys, Garnt and Joey,
and I am monkey-brain Connor.
- You didn't even say hello.
You just fucking opened
up with this like--
- That's what every good
sales pitch does, bro.
- Illuminati conspiracy theory.
- Every good sales pitch
starts with the hook.
- Literally reminded me of
that Wolf of Wall Street,
like, "Sell me this pen."
- Because now, they're
listening, they're intrigued.
"How can we get free anime?"
- What a hook, what a hook.
- They don't wanna know
about "Trash Taste."
They wanna know how they get free anime.
- Did you just do the OG...
(Garnt stammers)
Did you just...
Oh my God. I can't fucking talk today.
- Yeah, he did, he did.
- A natural salesman never
stumbles on his words.
I said free anime.
I wasn't stumbling.
- Tell me more, salesman,
who's totally not shady.
- Well, if you just go
to the Kickstarter page.
(Joey laughs)
- Oh, we're gonna talk about that.
We're gonna talk about that.
- Anime Tube, is that what
it's called, Anime Tube?
- Anime Tube.
- Well,
it's the first topic for today.
Two weeks ago, we wanted to
talk about this last week,
but Chris came on,
inconvenienced us again.
We would have spoken about this last week
- 'Cause we wanted to
talk about Anime Tube.
- We know Chris goes into
fits when we talk about anime.
- So we got, so we're gonna
be like three weeks late,
but the whole debacle
is kind of finished now.
- Yeah.
- We have all the info.
- Well, it like, lived
and died within the
span of a day, I think.
- [Connor] Yes.
- Pretty much.
- It was very interesting.
Essentially what happened is
this thing called Anime Tube
popped up on Kickstarter
and offered to give all
the kind, anyone, really--
- [Group] Free anime.
- Free anime?
- And you're probably thinking, "Well,
they probably only got like,
you know, C-rate shows,
you know, really terrible.
- What do they have?
They said they were going to,
they were in talks to get Evangelion,
(Joey gasps)
Love Hina, which has been
stuck in copyright Hell,
not copyright, licensing Hell.
- Specifically Love Hina. I dunno.
I dunno who just put
specifically picks Love Hina
to be on the list, but.
- Death Note, Attack on Titan.
- Full Metal Alchemist.
- Demon Slayer.
Even though these were already all on
streaming platforms already, you know.
And I imagine that--
- And the ones that aren't
have been out of print
for the past 20 years.
- They say Re:Zero as well.
- Ugh, I didn't, I didn't see the list.
- They've got everything. It's Anime Tube.
- You know? I mean, you know,
and so I can't,
I don't know how much
these properties are worth,
but I can't imagine you getting
Evangelion for less than
like a hundred million
or something ridiculous.
It sounds absurd, but it's
probably worth that much, right?
So clearly these guys have
big bucks to spend around.
- I mean, I'm just glad
a company is giving
the power back to the people
(Joey laughs)
and taking on small indie
companies like Sony.
- Fuck license holders, man!
- Taking on small indie
companies like Sony and AT&T.
You know, someone's gotta
take these indie companies
out of the field.
- What were they gonna do?
What were they gonna do with it?
So essentially this
Kickstarter promised that
and it raised in one day like $110,000.
- Which is absurd.
- It literally came out of
nowhere because I remember we were,
we literally came in the Trash
Taste studio in the morning
and then it was just all
over my Twitter timeline.
I was like, what the hell is going on?
And we all looked at it
and we were just like,
wait, this Kickstarter launched yesterday.
And it's raised over a
hundred thousand dollars,
promising people free anime legally.
And I'm just like,
what is going on right now?
It was an absolute disaster.
- April was about three months ago, guys.
(Garnt laughs)
You're a bit late to the joke right now.
- Yeah. It was just a mess.
- It was hilarious, dude.
- It was a mess.
The, you know,
I think it's so many levels to it,
there's so many things that
are really sad about it.
One, you know, I think
it's safe to say that
this was either the most
overambitious Kickstarter
of all time
or...
it was, they were lying.
(all laugh)
- Or the most genius scam.
- No, yeah, I mean, you know,
you have to be careful
when you say these gabs,
you can get sued.
So try not to get Trash
Taste sued here, Joey.
But from what I saw, yeah, it's a scam.
(Garnt laughs)
It's a scam.
- Well, I'm protecting myself.
I'm not going to say the S word,
but I'm going to say
that it looked very sus.
I'll say the other S word.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Little sussy scam.
- It's a sussy baka is what it is.
- You know, I genuinely wonder because,
you know, again,
they promised to have all
these titles that there's
absolutely, you know,
not even Netflix or Amazon
can get all of these shows,
right?
This is some serious amount of cash
and negotiating power,
that I doubt a Kickstarter
would be able to convince
the Japanese investors.
- If Netflix and Sony
can't even get the
rights to some of these,
what suggests to anyone that
this Kickstarter group will be able to?
- Evangelion literally couldn't be--
- Evangelion's been out of
print for the past 20 years.
- You couldn't get the license for it
until Netflix somehow managed,
probably don't even want to know
how much Netflix played for that.
- Anno, the creator, didn't
even have the rights to it
for the longest time
until he had to fucking fight
with Gainax to get it back.
- It's insanity.
- Yeah. I mean, the thing is,
I think there's, as you said,
there's so many layers
to it because, you know,
in theory, it's a nice idea.
You know,
having somewhere where you
can watch anime legally.
- Truly a utopian society.
- In this utopian world--
- One part of me feels bad.
'Cause we're like laughing at the,
imagine trying to take on the
big guy "ha ha ha, funny."
But if it was a good
attempt, I would be like,
"Go for it, go for it!"
- If it was a good attempt.
But keep in mind you're
taking on companies
like Sony, like Netflix,
you know, like people who, you know,
have a bit of dollar in
their pocket, you know?
- Just a bit.
- I don't think we're trying to be like,
yeah, we love corporations
and stuff like that.
- I feel like a lot of this was driven by,
you know, the people's
hatred towards corporations
and you know, I get it, you know.
If you don't want to
support the big corporations
because of whatever
reason, you know, I get it.
There's a difference between
not wanting to support big corporations
and then supporting whatever this is.
(Connor laughs)
- Blindly accepting
anything that you want.
- It's like not wanting to buy paracetamol
from your pharmacy, so you
go to the local drug dealer.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I guess so, in some sense.
- It's like bidding in a horse race,
but the horse has two legs.
- That's why I felt so, kind
of, just sad about it, really.
I felt sad that there was
enough weebs out there
that were this desperate to
stick it to the companies
that they would throw
their money into a void.
- Dude, weebs want free shit, man,
at the end of the day.
- That's the thing,
this is also what I don't understand,
is that we have weebs
that are this dedicated
to say fuck you to companies
that they're willing to give money away.
But you could, they could just pirate it,
if they really want to
really get it for free.
I'm not saying you should. I
condone that, do not do it.
But...
if you're gonna
(Connor blubbers)
- I mean, it's also like,
with the money that they
gave to this Kickstarter,
because there were a lot
of people who were giving
hundreds of dollars to this Kickstarter.
And some people I saw
were giving literally
thousands of dollars to this Kickstarter.
- When I looked, there
was a thousand backers
giving a hundred thousand, so.
- Rough, on average, a
hundred dollars each, right.
- They're giving a lot of money to this--
- That's like a year's
subscription to Netflix
or Crunchyroll or any of them.
- It's not about the money, Joey!
It's about the message I'm sending.
- It's about sending a
message, the message of
"I got scammed."
- I mean, it's the,
it's the thing is where,
if anyone just literally
used a single brain cell,
to think about the logistics of this--
- The logistics!
- Just the logistics of
why this would not work
in the first place or, you know.
A hundred thousand seems like
a lot of money to any normal person.
It's like a drop in the fucking bucket
for anime licensing
fees and all that stuff.
- You can maybe license--
- Half an episode.
- No, no, no, not even that.
(all laugh)
- You can maybe license the thumbnail.
- Half an episode of like a C-tier anime.
- Pretty much, yeah.
What surprised me is that they were,
the shows that they were listing
as the shows they were going for,
were like the fucking triple A titles
that are worth millions and
millions of dollars, right?
I mean, God knows how
much Netflix actually paid
to get Evangelion out of licensing hell.
'Cause Evangelion was out of like,
couldn't be licensed by any
Western company for like,
feels like a decade or something.
- Literally since it was made.
- Yeah.
Since ADV collapsed,
I can't think of any other
company that has successfully
licensed Evangelion.
- And I think people
like to think of anime
as still this kind of underground thing,
but some of these shows
are easily, you know,
worth over hundreds of
millions of dollars.
Just think of the merchandising
of these shows as well.
The IP is so expensive.
- Think about the mega shows,
any of the Shonen Jump shows like My Hero.
- How much is Attack on Titan worth?
- Fucking Demon Slayer.
- Oh, I mean, Demon Slayer
is a billion dollar property.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly!
- It's already proven to be that.
- Yeah.
- It's really,
I just, I don't understand.
Like every, none of this,
who were these thousands
of people who gave money?
I legitimately want to know.
- Yeah, I legitimately want to know.
- It's obviously very young,
impressionable anime fans,
right, who were just hoping
for this utopian society?
- I wonder if some parts of it,
we're just completely oblivious about,
whether we take for granted some of them,
'cause we,
I mean, we work with Japanese companies.
We know how these things are.
You can't go around
saying you're in talks.
That is,
that is like the biggest
no-no in business.
And especially here,
I feel like it's never a done deal
until it's done deal in Japan.
- Did you read the FAQ?
- What was the, what did they say?
Oh, okay.
I've read some of it. What was the,
do you remember the thing
about licensing or something?
- I remember one of the FAQ's,
one of the questions was,
"Isn't anime licensing really expensive?"
- Yes.
(all laugh)
And they legit went,
"Actually, anime licensing
isn't as expensive
as everyone makes it out to be.
The only reason nobody does it
and nobody talks about
it is because of NDAs.
But we are in talks with
real Japanese anime licenses.
And that was pretty much,
that was pretty much the
answer to the question,
"Can they get anime licenses?"
- They literally just shot
themselves in the foot.
They didn't have to answer that question.
- You can't say you're
talking to these companies.
It's all very secretive,
you know, intentionally.
- All these companies are like,
"Do you know this guy?"
Well, yeah, 'cause if it
was a guy, there was a,
so they also,
I think the person, I'm
not sure if the CEO,
someone representing write staff.
Anime.
Which is the American company, I think.
which buys the licenses for,
again, I'm not sure.
Either way, they buy
licensing or they sell,
or they sell DVDs of anime.
They reached out being like,
"So apparently you've
listed some of our titles,
and you say that we're in talks."
And the guy tweeted at him, saying that
"We've never been in talks."
And then they replied saying,
"We sent you a message on LinkedIn.
That was there. We're in talks."
I'm in fucking talks
with all the people that
email me about weird shit then, aren't I?
The fuck?
- It's just like,
"Bro, I DM'ed you.
Why didn't you DM back?"
- "I sent you my LinkedIn
DM, please respond.
(Garnt laughs)
We're in talks now, right?
Hundreds of millions
of dollars are at stake
because of my LinkedIn DM."
- "I sent you a DM, please
give me the anime license."
- "Please give me the IP."
That's how
anime licensing works, right?
- I'm in talks with
all my favorite succubuses
from all the hentai.
I've sent them a message.
They haven't responded
yet, but we're in talks.
We're working on an arrangement.
It's just insanity.
- We're part of this
one-sided conversation.
- It was just,
(Connor laughs)
I mean, it all burned
down in flames, luckily,
but it was just, oh my God,
it was such a fucking mess.
- It was just
so bizarre to see.
And, you know, we knew it was
gonna come down in flames.
- [Connor] Hundred percent.
I mean, I think right now,
it's been taken off Kickstarter, right?
- As far as I know.
- Can you check?
- [Navi] It's still here.
- [Group] It's still there?
- [Navi] But the funding has stopped.
- Oh.
- Okay.
So, no one's giving them anymore funding.
- That's good.
- [Navi] Okay, it does say "suspended."
- So, Kickstarter suspended the bitch.
- $111,000.
I don't know how true this is,
but I did see a screenshot
pop up on my timeline
the other day though,
that shows that they haven't given up.
They've started a
newsletter, which you can,
which you can subscribe to for a dollar.
So for a dollar,
for this newsletter,
you can subscribe for updates.
- These people are just taking your money.
- Updates of what?
Talks in the anime industry?
- I don't know!
I legit don't know.
- "On this week's newsletter,
we're in talks with ADV."
(Joey laughs)
Trying to get the rights.
- It's just absolutely tragic.
It's obvious that, you know,
I'm not being funny,
but there's a reason why
Netflix doesn't have its
own Discord server as well.
They had their own Discord server,
and they started banning people.
And it's like, what is this?
This is a fucking YandereDev's game.
What is this? This is
like, what's going on here?
And it's so obvious that they're just,
'cause they've done this like
two times before apparently,
as well.
And they failed twice.
- Oh, yeah! I saw they've made
other Kickstarters.
- So they're trying to make
this Kickstarter. This is their
third attempt of doing it.
And I think that another
app similar to it popped up
on the Microsoft store and
was taken down before as well.
They have a history of doing
this and failing and whatever,
but clearly, you know,
every time it comes around,
it seems to get some
money. So I guess, why not?
- They got some real balls to do it
like three or four times.
- No shame, man, if you get money.
- I'm sorry if you fucking
gave money to that Kickstarter.
- Yeah, I mean, I would say,
I like the idea of it.
- Noble intentions.
- Intentions aside, I like the idea of it.
- Everybody wishes for it.
- I mean, everybody wishes for it.
'Cause I feel like, you know,
in the era we're in now,
I think we're past the golden
age of streaming because
we're past the point in time
where you could get every show
that you physically, feasibly
watched on one platform.
And it's unfortunate that that's the case,
but it's kind of evolved
into a similar era
to what the cable era was like.
But I mean, when pe--
when corporations started to realize that
there was money in streaming,
this was going to be the way
that things were gonna evolve,
unfortunately,
because unfortunately,
money talks, you know.
And if there could be a platform
where every anime you ever
watched was on a single platform,
I'm sure someone would
have done that already.
I'm sure someone with a lot of money
would have done that already.
- Hate to be the bearer of bad news,
but anime is a business.
(Garnt laughs)
Whether you like it or not.
- Streaming is one of
those businesses where it's
now on impossible to get into it,
unless you've got massive investors.
- Maybe like 10, 15 years ago.
- [Connor] Yeah.
Maybe, you know,
if you were at the start
of the streaming age,
like when Crunchyroll first started,
but that time's passed now.
You can't just be the little guy
taking on the big guy anymore.
- Quibi as well had like,
what, 6 billion dollars.
- The fuck is Quibi?
- Yeah, exactly! You don't
even know what Quibi is.
- Wait, what's Quibi?
It's a, it was made,
it was founded by the guy who
left Disney and founded DreamWorks.
I can't remember his name.
And made Quibi, a streaming service.
- Oh my god,
I remember that shit.
- It was an absolute
dumpster fire, but it had
billions of dollars in investments.
It was insane.
- Yeah, but it disappeared
after like two weeks, right? Or something.
- Well, it was like, you got a free trial
then you have to pay.
And it literally just tanked immediately.
They paid for so many
original shows as well.
- Who's on there?
- I don't fucking know.
I didn't go on Quibi.
(Garnt laughs)
- Did anyone use Quibi?
- I didn't even know about this.
- Oh yeah. How'd you not know about this?
- It was a couple of years ago, I think.
- Was it a couple years ago?
- It was like two years ago, I think.
No, it was like a year ago.
- Was it?
- I think I might've--
I don't even count last year.
Last year, frankly, just flew by.
I can't remember anything.
- Did it happen in
2019? It was a year ago.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I'm still 22 as far as I'm concerned.
(all laugh)
- 2020 was just like fucking
King Crimson existed in 2020,
and just fucking erased the entire year.
We just skipped it.
- Literally felt like
last month was April 2020.
This is really weird.
- Yeah, I mean we're already
halfway through 2021,
which is terrifying.
- Didn't Mixer die as well?
- Yeah. Mixer died.
- Man, fuck, I wish I got
offered to move to Mixer.
I would've got a nice cash out.
- Ninja's just set for life.
He's the only reason anyone
knows about Mixer, I think.
But yeah, I mean, even with
those failed platforms,
they had millions and billions
of dollars invested into them
by angel investors.
- They definitely wouldn't
start up a fucking Kickstarter.
- And unfortunately,
even if you have, what's,
what would be the most successful
Kickstarter of all time?
- I don't know.
- That's very telling that
we can't think of one.
- [Group] Yeah.
I'm sure there is some good
ones out there, I just,
I've never been interested.
Any good Kickstarter,
you could just buy the thing
when it fucking comes out.
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause I'm just thinking of the money,
with the money that Kickstarter can be,
people can invest into Kickstarter.
Even the most successful
Kickstarter of all time would
probably have trouble getting
into the streaming field.
- The only one I remember was those
sunglasses that had the
built-in headphones into it.
Remember those?
- That was successful?
- There was a Kickstarter,
I remember it because it
was during my uni days,
but there's this pair of
sunglasses where on the brim here,
it was like this new
technology and audio where
it would vibrate, and the
vibrations would travel
through your ears and the music
would come into your ears.
And I remember it was a successful case
that was millions of dollars.
- That's not success.
- Is that the most successful
Kickstarter of all time?
- Wait, what the fuck is that?
- The Ouya.
- [Group] The Ouya?
- The Ouya is the most successful?
Are you kidding me, Navi?
- [Navi] Number eight.
- Oh, number eight.
The Ouya is the number--
- Wait, how much money did the Ouya raise?
- [Navi] $8,596,000.
- Yeah, but you gotta bear in mind, right,
even if someone raised--
- [Navi] Most successful
is actually Pebble
with 20 million dollars.
- [All] Pebble?
- [Man] The smartwatch.
- Oh!
- Even if somebody raised
200, 300 million dollars,
that doesn't mean shit for streaming.
You can't buy much with that.
- No, that's what I'm trying to say.
Even with the most successful
Kickstarters of all time,
to get into this field, you
need external investors.
If they really want to challenge
the big guys, you know,
'cause there's a lot of
money in there right now.
- Most of us are broke!
- You could gather all the
anime fans in the world
and it probably won't even be enough.
- I don't understand how people
can invest in Kickstarter
after it's just,
track record's poorly.
- Have you ever donated to a Kickstarter?
- No!
- Why? You save like $20,
and you got to put a
hundred in for some shit.
And it's like, I'll just
wait 'til it comes out.
- I've done a few,
but not like the stupid amounts
of money that some people--
every time I look at a Kickstarter,
and I see, you know, the top tiers,
which are like a thousand, $10,000,
and you see one left, two left.
I'm like, who are these people
that are just dropping $10,000 on this?
- For stuff that
genuinely needs the money,
I would be more inclined.
Like a game or something that I'm into.
I would, but I haven't though.
Most of the time, the
stuff that gets the most
is just like fucking
pre-orders, essentially.
The product's made, they
know what they're doing,
and you're just pre-ordering.
- Yeah, I mean, with Kickstarter,
I feel like if it's a small indie project
or something that you can see
feasibly getting funded on
Kickstarter, I would support it.
I think the last Kickstarter
I supported was actually
the Trigger anime.
I think they funded the second OVA of
- [Joey And Garnt] Little Witch Academia.
- I supported that.
- That makes sense to me, that seems like,
this is why Kickstarter should exist.
- But if you're coming
in trying to change,
stir up an entire industry or whatever,
Kickstarter's just not
going to do it anymore.
I think Kickstarter is
really good for, you know,
a small indie team to
do some kind of project,
but on like a fucking
industry changing project,
you need something else.
- Usually Kickstarter is for, you know,
kind of at a,
it stops at an artistic level, right?
It's not really the thing
that you go into to be like,
I'm gonna cause a scene
in the industry, you know?
- Fucking everything on
Kickstarter is the same shit.
It's like, all right,
get the stock image of people running,
play the music mood and the, you know--
- The ukulele one.
- That one or there's always
some motivational thing.
And then it's just like,
have you ever had this
problem that isn't a problem?
Well, now we can solve it.
And then it looks amazing.
And then you think about
it and you're like,
it's all shit.
(Joey laughs)
- It's always the same type of people
with a Kickstarter too, isn't it?
It's always the way too
overly enthusiastic, like,
"Hi, my name is Kyle."
- It'll either be someone from California
or someone from Eastern Europe.
With a really thick accent explaining why
his fridge is the best fridge.
And it's like, okay,
that's cool, that's fine.
I just don't want it.
- "With our last project,
'The Walking Fridge,'
we raised $200,000.
That's insane."
- I just realized that Kickstarters
are basically the modern infomercials.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Pretty much.
I just don't believe
any single advertisement
where someone gives it to a random person
and they're like, "Whoa, it's amazing."
I just don't believe that.
Even if it actually happens,
I just don't want to see it.
- I don't even believe it when
there's the thing which
says "not a paid actor."
You sure about that?
(Garnt laughs)
- Going back to Anime Tube,
did you see the fucking
testimonials they had
on the Kickstarter post page?
- What were the testimonials?
- I think they just got some random people
they found on Discord to
give them testimonials
of their app or something like that.
- "It's good!"
(Garnt laughs)
- What were the testimonials?
- Let me see, let me see.
Let me see if I can bring it up right now,
But...
Yeah, I mean, it's all the same, right?
It's literally--
- Let's see.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, you know,
I frankly don't really do,
I don't trust anyone who
shows me their review.
Just let me see your
reviews. I'll have a look.
- [Joey] "It is routinely
maintained, it's comfortable,
it's quite logical and ergonomic.
It's way beyond any
competition. I like it."
- Of course it's beyond
the fucking competition
when you can just take the
licenses and rip them off a DVD.
- [Joey] "The best app for on-hand anime.
I used to spend days looking up series,
but now I just use this app with ease."
Thank you, Robert.
- [Garnt] Thank you,
Stephan, Robert, and James.
- [Joey] With the most rudimentary anime
profile pictures. I've ever seen.
- Yeah. I mean, it's just,
we're going to look back on this
and it's just going to feel
like a fever dream, you know.
(Joey laughs)
- It already does.
- It's fucking stupid.
- Don't do that!
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- Guys, we all shop online
and we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to Honey,
manually searching for
coupons like a peasant
is the thing of the past.
- [Garnt] Honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
It supports over 30,000 stores online.
Right now.
- That's a lot of stores.
- That's incredible.
- All right, boys, hear
me out, hear me out.
Imagine you're shopping on
your favorite site, right?
And when you're at the checkout,
the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do
is click Apply Coupons.
You wait a few seconds
as Honey searches for its coupons
it can find for that site,
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch those prices
drop!
(Connor and Garnt groan)
- Joey, stop seducing me like this.
I can't hear these words right now.
I'm literally coming.
- I recently bought a new pair
of noise canceling headphones,
and thanks to Honey, I
saved twenty dollarinos.
And I'm not the only Honey
member making savings.
There's over 17 million members
getting those sweet savings
worth 2 billion dollars.
- If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
just takes a few seconds.
And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a favor
and you'll be supporting us as well.
- I'd never recommend
something that I don't use.
So get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste,
that's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Link's in the description below.
- Back to the episode.
I don't trust reviews on
websites that aren't like
a third party's website.
You know what I mean?
- Even some third party websites, right?
- Even Amazon, they're all fucked, right?
And especially if it's on your website.
Bro, I don't trust your reviews.
Five stars? No way. It's on your website.
- I just don't trust
Amazon reviews in general.
Especially in Japan.
- I mean, we've talked about
this before, right, to be fair.
But I mean, that's why they
have the certified seller thing.
A certified buyer bought
it, which makes more sense.
- We need more people like Meilyne.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, Meilyne reviews--
- Hit them with the hard
opinions! No bullshit.
- Meilyne, Meilyne,
the top 5% Google reviewer.
- I just feel like
I'm a shit reviewer.
'Cause I don't really give a shit,
as long as it does the thing.
I don't care, some people get so--
- Have you ever written a review
for an Amazon thing or anything?
- I'm always five or one star.
I'm that guy, I'm that kind of guy.
Because to me, it either
works or it doesn't.
And if it looks fine, fine, that's it.
- If it does the thing
I paid for it to do--
- Five stars.
- That's great.
- You're not those assholes who are like,
"Two out of ten. The box
was bruised." Or whatever.
- Well, people rate
furniture and they're like,
"It was complicated to build. Two stars."
And I'm like,
but that's surely, that's just--
- That's on you, bro.
- Yeah, I feel like that's
an interpretation thing.
Is the thing good?
At the end of the day,
you're only going to build it
for like one hour or two hours or three.
- There are some times
when I'm just like how,
I'm pretty sure you
need a PhD to translate
the instruction manual
that they gave, right?
- Every IKEA furniture.
- I know what you mean
but at the same time,
okay, I have a coffee table right now.
that was so over-engineered
and the amount of screws and
shit for it was totally stupid.
That was three hours
out of the two years I've been using it.
I don't give a shit
about those three hours
looking back now.
That's why I write the
review like three months
after I get it, because then I'm like,
oh yeah, it's good.
- It's still standing.
- That's why I wait. If it
breaks up after like one month,
all right, fine, that's one star.
It shouldn't have broke
one month after I use it.
But when people who,
these people who write
it and they're like,
"The cardboard box was
slightly damaged, you know.
The furniture took a little
longer than I'd like to.
Like, fuck off.
- "The delivery man had a bad attitude."
That's got nothing to do with anything.
- And then as well, even
if it breaks, I'm like,
all right, how long, reasonably,
did I expect it to last?
My bed's broken,
is that,
but it's two years,
is that--
- You also spent, what,
a hundred bucks on it?
- It was 300 bucks for
the mattress and the bed.
- Which is very cheap
for a bed of your size.
- Considering how much
we've spent on Amazon
to get our first furniture,
I think the furniture I have
right now has lasted very well.
- Well, my bed is like,
this design of this bed is,
when I was building it, I'm like, huh.
This doesn't seem super
structurally stable.
I understand why it was three stars now.
Well, basically, you know that meme
with the Cheeto in the door,
holding the door closed?
There's a tiny plank,
like a piece of plywood
that basically is holding up
the middle of the bed
and all the way on it.
- That doesn't sound safe.
- No.
- If you stood on that and jumped on it,
it would just crack, right?
Well, one time,
I think I just like,
'cause I don't know,
I wouldn't say I get
into bed aggressively,
but I'm not polite about it.
- You're not gonna be like--
- I'm not sneaking into my bed, you know,
I just kinda like, you know.
- Hop on, yeah.
- Just fucking does a
clothesline on the bed
or something like that.
- WWE Smackdown Arena!
No, so I just popped on my
bed and I just heard the boom.
And then I looked under my bed
and this thing had just
fucking went to the side.
And I was like, oh, that's all right.
- It's not even screwed in?
- No, no. It's literally
just put in with the weight.
(Joey laughs)
There's just a plank of literally,
like if this is the bed--
(Connor mumbles)
It's just like this.
You just gotta center this piece of wood.
It's literally like this size as well.
And so when I looked and it was like this.
I was just like, oh, it's all right.
(Joey laughs)
So I do that every time it does it now.
- I mean, that works, right?
- It's probably time for a new bed, man.
- Yeah, probably time for a new bed.
I mean, you're moving soon,
gonna upgrade your breads, which--
- Bread? My bread?
- Upgrading my breads.
- I do have to
upgrade my bread.
- From white to rye.
- You can feel the springs on it
and everything right now, can't you?
- I kinda like feeling
the springs, though.
- Why?
- Really?
- It's got a nice feel to it, you know?
- I don't.
Does no one else,
someone else is like that.
I like feeling a little bit of a spring.
- We're looking around the room,
not a single person is like, "Mhm!"
- Sounds like peasant talk to me.
- Listen, okay. I'm--
Shut up.
(Garnt laughs)
- How dare you?
- No king wants to feel the
springs on the bread corner.
- Stop saying bread!
(all laugh)
- What is your obsession with bread?
I don't want springs in
my fucking bread, Garnt.
That'd be really awkward,
trying to cut it.
- The knife keeps bouncing back!
- It's a slinky in my bread!
Well, I,
you know, when I go to a hotel,
I have their amazing, you know--
Fucking whatever the little hippo is.
The brand, I don't know
what it is. Sleepy's?
- The anti-gravity mattress
or whatever the fuck it's called.
- The hippo. It's Sleepy's, the brand.
I think it's a hippo in the UK.
- Is that a brand?
- Anyway, it's some deluxe,
divine, 10,000 sheet.
I'm like, oh, it's pretty good, this.
It's great, that.
But also, those beds are ridiculous.
And I don't,
I don't think they're that
much better than a shitty bed.
- I don't know about that, man.
- I don't know about that one, chief.
- You know a shit mattress
when you're on it.
- Yeah.
- I had a memory foam
one at my parents' house.
- I don't like memory foam ones.
Those ones, I don't like.
- Really? I love those.
- When I first--
Well, yeah, it's 'cause
you gotta break it in.
You really,
after like a year, it's amazing.
- It's like putty, you just
kind of sink yourself into it.
- It takes months for it to
actually get the right shape.
But then it's amazing.
- No, I want to see,
feel some bounce in it.
With the memory foam one,
it feels like I'm sleeping in quicksand.
Where you just sink in and you just like--
- Yeah, that's the thing though,
the comfort envelops you.
- But the thing is, you know, I mean,
I feel like that's like
admitting you're just single
if you get a memory foam one.
It's not an exciting bed, you know?
- What do you mean?
- Do I need to explain, Garnt?
- Yeah, please.
- There's no bounce.
(Connor laughs)
- I gotcha.
(all laugh)
- It's just depressing.
It's like fucking on a beanbag, you know.
- I don't use memory foam beds, so.
- There you go, then,
you know what I mean.
- 'Cause I like the bounce.
I like the bounce normally
when I'm sleeping, you know.
- What are you, fucking
sleeping like this?
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- You can rebound them.
(Garnt laughs)
- I need some bounce when I'm fighting
my sleep paralysis demon.
Get off!
- Do I really need to
explain this? Come on.
- I get it. I get it.
- Sometimes, you know--
- Sometimes, you just wanna
play a bit of basketball, right?
(Joey laughs)
- Sometimes you just
wanna dribble some balls.
- Yeah, sometimes, you need to dribble.
You know what I mean?
Could you catch my drift guys?
Use your imagination.
- Spring breads are awful for that.
- [Connor] No, you can use
the springs.
- Stop saying bread!
- I said bed there, didn't I?
- You literally said, "Spring bread."
- Oh my fucking God.
(Connor laughs)
- Does Garnt go to the bakery
and ask for a mattress?
(all laugh)
- Give me your finest bed, please.
- Oh my God, what is this fucking convo?
- Have you ever slept
on a waterbed before?
- I imagine that must be fun.
- That sounds horrible.
- That's really fun. It's like literally--
- That must be. Is it actually
fun? Is it comfortable?
- It's really,
I find it to be super fucking comfortable,
but that's because again, it's,
but I find memory foam
to be really comfortable.
So it's kind of like that because
the mattress kind of follows
you as you're moving around.
- But then if you're in a--
- It's like you become the mattress.
- If you get a double
memory foam mattress,
you guys are never going
to touch each other.
You guys are going to be like,
"We have our crevice. It is set. Goodbye."
- That's what I don't like
about memory foam mattresses.
You just sink in, and there--
- It's a single bed thing.
- There's no movement.
I'm not seeing enough movement anywhere
on a memory foam mattress
You sink in and that's just it.
- That's what couples
do when they agree that
they're just not having sex anymore.
It's true, I mean--
- It's like, "Let me just
sink into my crevice."
- Well, yeah, because you have your,
you literally,
if a memory foam is set,
it's so uncomfortable
to move to a position where it isn't set.
- What about memory foam pillows?
- Oh yeah, I like the pillows.
- Do you like the pillows?
- Nah, I like feeling that,
I like a little resistance,
I like a little bounce.
On like whatever I'm sleeping--
- You fucking the pillow, Garnt?
(all laugh)
- I like when the pillow fights back.
- Garnt's like suffocating Sydney.
(all laugh)
- I like it when the pillow's hard to get.
- I think the pillow needs
a little bit of firmness.
- I like it when the pillow's
a tsundere, you know?
- If you sink in too much, then--
- I do like being able to,
if I'm kind of just not
happy with the pillow,
I can just like.
(Connor pants)
- [Joey] Punch the shit of it. Yeah.
- Yeah, literally.
Until you're like, all
right, it is refreshed.
- Yeah, 'cause sometimes,
you just gotta fucking
tenderize the pillow, right?
Fucking get the fucking steak tenderized.
You want to go like--
(Garnt grunts)
All right. Now it's puff.
I used to...
I used to use two pillows exclusively,
but now for some reason I can't use two.
Is that getting old? Is that an old thing?
- No, I've actually gone the opposite.
I used to be able to
just sleep on one pillow,
but now I need two.
- I can't do two anymore.
It has to be one.
- Why?
- I dunno.
Maybe 'cause my,
when I was a child, sorry,
my mom probably bought the
shittest, thinnest pillows.
Maybe that was why.
So I was like, yeah, I
always sleep with two,
and I'm like this.
(Joey laughs)
Yeah, I always sleep with two pillows.
- No, I was the opposite.
I had the really, really
thin pillows, right.
And we couldn't afford another pillow.
So I was just like, yeah, yeah.
- I think that's why I had two.
- I was like,
why am I waking up with
a headache every morning?
Oh, it's because all the
blood is rushing to my head
from being like this.
- Japan has these pillows
that you get in hotels
and stuff that I hate.
- Which ones?
- Like double-sided ones, but--
- Double-sided? Aren't
all pillows double-sided?
- No, no.
There's two different types
of material on each side.
- [Joey and Garnt] Oh!
And one of them is literally
like solid beanbag.
It's like a bean bag that you have to
physically move around to--
- It's the sand one, right?
- Yeah, it's horrible.
- I love those ones.
- And it's sticking into
your neck.
No, what? What?
- I love, you know, when
you're sleeping on a futon,
the sand pillows that you get--
- No, I hate those.
Give me something soft.
- I love those because it,
again, it gives me that
perfect height where it
makes me sleep so well.
- Did you just say sand pillows?
- It feels like sand.
- It's like a beads sand.
- Oh!
- It's rock solid, though.
- It's like if you packed
a bean bag a little,
with too much beans.
- Yeah, I stayed in a hotel one time.
And I was like, when I left, I was like,
fuck that, that fucking
sand. It was horrible.
Oh, you could've just
flipped it. I'm like, what?
- I didn't know that.
- Most of them are two-sided.
So the other side will be a normal pillow.
- Oh. I always just like go to the hotel,
just touch the sand side.
I'm like, I'm satisfied.
I'll take that.
- I hate the sand.
- Maybe 'cause I used to sleep with those
at my grandma's place.
'Cause that's all she had.
- It just makes me feel
like I'm in a hospital.
I don't know why.
- Hospital? But the
hospitals have super pillows
that kind of go around you like this.
You sink in and it's just like--
- I don't know.
I don't think,
I've never stayed in a hospital.
- You've never stayed in a hospital?
- No.
- I've stayed in a hospital once.
- I'm trying to remember if
I have. I definitely have.
It's just, it's not a
common occurrence obviously.
(all laugh)
Maybe I have some time in my childhood.
- Just taking a weekly trip
to the hospital, just, casual.
- It's a free hotel in
the UK if you get injured.
- Have you ever injured your--
have you ever been to the hospital,
with an injury and stuff like that?
Have we ever talked about that?
Like you've injured yourself so bad
that you had to go to the hospital.
- No.
- Like breaking a bone or anything.
- I've never had any bad
injuries, I don't think.
- No. You?
I had once. I have stitches.
You can still kind of see
it right there on my finger.
That was the only time.
'Cause I fell when I was two years old
and I landed kind of
like my hands like that,
and a piece of glass just
went straight into there.
So they had to pull it
out and give me stitches.
But that's about it, really.
- Damn, that was a boring--
- Yeah, that was boring.
- I was hoping you guys would have
hurt yourselves, you know?
- Connor's like, the time
I fucking crashed a car.
- I was like, guys, broken
bone? Please, please?
- Guys, any injuries?
- Are we that boring, that
we haven't injured ourselves?
- I have strong bones,
I don't know what you're talking about.
- I drink my milk, bro.
- I've had some pretty bad injuries.
But for some reason I just never had,
never been like,
I've always been like,
walk it off, walk it off.
- It's just your arm falling off--
- I probably have broken
my toe or something
and just not known about it.
- That's pretty common, though.
- I feel like it's pretty common.
- I've sprained my wrist. Did that.
- That's like the most
boring injury of all time.
"Sprained my wrist, uh, yeah."
- Yeah. It was from like,
I think I told the story when I,
I failed a jump skiing
or snowboarding, right.
And that was fucking horrible.
I thought I was gonna die, but I was like,
I'll snowboard it off.
I just kept snowboarding,
and I was winded as fuck.
- That's how you know we're inside kids,
when we haven't broken
any bones or anything.
- What are you expecting, Joey?
- I don't know, man!
- We're fucking anime nerds and gamers.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- I've been very lucky.
- Wanking yourself so hard
you dislocate your wrist
or something, I don't know.
- I think about all the injuries I've had
and how I've just never
had any damage from it.
And I'm like, that's very lucky.
Tipped a quad bike, when
I was like ten, on myself.
- And you didn't go to the hospital?
- I wasn't injured at all.
- Tipped a quad bike on
yourself. How'd you do that?
- Well, I tipped a quad bike.
'Cause you know, my mate owned a farm
and I loved going to his house
'cause it was just basically
like a free theme park.
Farms are great when you're
ten, cause it's like--
- Especially with a quad bike.
- He had a quad bike!
And his dad didn't give a shit.
He was just like, "You can
just go on the quad bike."
So he just let us go on the quad bike.
And I was like one of those
fucking danger addicts
when I was a 10 year old.
I just wanted to do dangerous things.
So my friend, he was used
to going on the quad bike,
and he was just like,
"Yeah, it's all right.
Just don't go too fast."
And I was like, all right.
Immediately went too fast.
I was just turning really, really fast.
And when I was going so fast,
the bike just went like, oh.
It just flipped over,
did like a barrel roll.
So, it tipped, but I think
I was small enough where,
I don't know how it happened,
but it tipped, I didn't get hurt at all.
And I just got up, and the
bar was a little fucked
on the thing, but we hit it
into place and it was good.
And then I went back on it.
- You went back on it?
- Yeah!
- I would not fucking go
back on it if I flipped.
- I was like, yeah, dude, that was so fun.
Let's do it again!
- "Almost died, let's do it again!"
- Have you guys had any
near-death experiences before?
- I've told the story about how I
got launched with a bounce castle, right?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- That was probably level one as well.
- I remember telling
you this a few days ago,
but I think the nearest
death experience I had was
probably the most lamest
story I could tell,
but it was during a snowball fight, right?
So, in university in England,
we don't get a lot of snow.
We get snow once or twice a year, right?
And so anytime it snows,
everyone takes the opportunity
to play around in the snow.
And in university, what that means is
we just go out and have a bunch
of snowball fights, right?
So it was one dorm versus another dorm.
And we were having a snowball fight
in the middle of this residential
area in Bristol, right?
So it wasn't in the middle
of a field or something,
it was literally on the
roads and the pavements.
And I remember we were
just throwing snowballs and
one fucker, right,
you know, you have the snowballs and some,
the common courtesy is you
make the powder snowballs.
And you throw those.
- Yes, of course, of course.
Of course.
- One fucker decided to make an ice ball.
You know what I mean.
The ones where it's like melted ice
and you fucking pack it in and--
- On the side of the road.
- On the side of the road
where you just like--
- At least he didn't put a stone in it.
People used to do that in my school.
- Seriously?
- I had that as well.
- I feel like ice balls are even worse
because you get the hardness of the ice
and the coldness as well,
which is numbing as well.
- It's basically just getting
a cold rock thrown at you.
- So I was standing right
by the side of the road
and I see the snowball coming
and I'm just like, it's
a snowball, whatever.
Hits my fucking balls.
And then I realize, number one,
that is perfect aim because
it literally hit my balls.
Number two, that is not
a snowball I just felt.
That is a solid ice ball
that just came full force,
right to my fucking balls.
- I have a really similar story,
but except total opposite.
It was at the beach.
And my dad and I were at the beach,
I think I was like maybe 11, 12 years old.
And my dad and I were kicking
the rugby ball around.
One thing I really liked
was trying to catch
the ball that gets kicked really high up,
and then you kind of get under
it and grab it like that.
So we were doing that a couple of times.
I was practicing that.
And one time my dad just kicks
it really fucking high up.
And I was like, all right, I got it.
Sun's in my eyes, but I
got it. I think I got this.
And it comes down,
it misses my arm,
and it just perfectly flicks my knob.
(Garnt laughs)
- It just flicks it.
That's worse!
- It didn't even land on my
balls. It just flicked it.
It just went, "pow," like that on my knob.
And I just collapsed.
- 'Cause if you're not a
guy, if you're not a male,
it's really hard to
describe the pain you feel
when your knob gets flicked or some,
you feel an impact on it.
- It's not your dick or balls that hurt.
It's above it that hurts.
- It's just the entire area.
- It's the flick. The flick
hurts the most for some reason.
- And so obviously this happened to me
and I was in total agony, right.
Because your mind just goes blank.
So I start walking forward
and I didn't realize I was
walking right into the
middle of the road, right.
- Jesus Christ!
- Because I was just like,
(Garnt groans)
(Joey laughs)
And then the last thing
I remember is my mate go,
"Garnt, what the fuck?"
And he grabs my bag and
pulls me back, right.
He full on pulls me back
and then I just see this
fucking bus just going
(Garnt imitates bus screeching)
right in front of me.
And yeah, that was the closest
I've come to dying, I think.
- Imagine dying while grabbing your balls.
- I think you actually just missed out
on your own Isekai story.
(Garnt laughs)
- That was your chance.
That was your one chance.
- Yeah, that was literally
an Isekai origin story.
Yeah, I got an ice ball in my balls.
- Now I wanna watch an Isekai story
that literally starts out like that,
where the protagonist
gets smashed in the balls,
and then gets transported
to another world.
- Jesus Christ, that's scary.
I don't know if I've had
any near-death experiences.
I had a really stupid accident one time.
We had one of those big trampolines,
like the...
the big ones.
There's two sizes, right?
The small and then there's a big one.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Had one of those.
And I loved doing front flips, back flips,
all the works on it.
You name it, I jumped it, right.
- I jumped it. I flipped it.
- And one time, I was like,
I'm just gonna do it on my knees.
I was practicing doing tricks on my knees.
And one time I just did
something, landed on my knees.
And instead of me jumping
back, my back just went like,
while I was still on my
knees, so my back just--
- [Joey] Oh, Jesus.
And I was like,
I've never had this pain in my life.
I wanted to throw up immediately,
and I couldn't move.
- Probably just winded yourself, right?
- I don't know what I did,
but it was fucking horrible.
Scared the shit out of me.
I was so winded and it was horrible.
It was so horrible.
I was like twelve and I
was like, what's happening?
Why do I wanna throw up? Oh God.
- That must've been scary
for people watching you
where you, literally your back just goes--
- No one was there. It was just me.
- Damn. You could've died
on that trampoline.
- Where was this trampoline?
- It was at my house.
- Oh, you had a trampoline at your house?
- Yeah.
- Your parents are like, "He's probably
having fun on the trampoline."
Meanwhile, he's like,
(Joey moans)
"Help!"
- Having a trampoline
at your house was great
when your friends came over,
'cause you can just fucking fight on it.
- Yeah, we didn't have a backyard
big enough for a trampoline.
- I didn't have that much space.
- Our backyard's pretty big.
- Well, you're a country boy, aren't you?
- Well, it's Wales.
(all chatter)
Most people have a pretty
decent sized backyard.
It was really good though.
I mean, yeah, it's great.
We'd just fight on it and stuff.
- As you do.
- So in other news, Japan
is back on lockdown.
- No way!
- Well, you know what, we
had a pleasant two weeks.
- Yeah, we had two weeks out of lockdown.
- What blows my mind is that
they cancel spectators now
for the Olympics.
It's starting this month, right?
- Yeah, in a couple weeks.
- What the fuck?
- Actually, by the time this is up,
it's probably already started.
- It's insane to me that
they canceled it this,
the spectators this late when, you know--
- But the athletes are
still allowed in, right?
- I mean, I get that.
But as if they didn't know
how bad the situation was,
it's like, "Whoa, shit,
it didn't get better
suddenly? What the fuck?"
To me, it's insane that,
you know, it's also just
irresponsible as well
because there's probably people
who booked hotels, you know?
'Cause even in Japan, right,
you can come from Hokkaido,
wherever the fuck you are,
you can come and watch.
Poor people probably booked
time off work, maybe,
probably booked some hotels.
- Yeah, they use their limited pay leave.
- It's like the Cyberpunk release,
but just on a scale ten
times that, you know.
(Garnt laughs)
- If somebody booked
time off work in Japan,
they ain't playing around.
That doesn't happen.
- The Japanese government
just puts out a tweet,
which is just the fucking--
- The yellow--
- TwitLonger thing.
- We have delayed the Olympics again.
(Garnt laughs)
- We have canceled
spectators. We apologize.
- I mean, it's just, yeah,
unfortunately you're not,
we're going to have to wait even longer
for the new Figure episode
because we're still
under a new lockdown and it
just feels like this entire year
has just been a lockdown.
But not really, for us.
It feels like now that
the rest of the world
is kind of getting back to normal,
it's really weird seeing timelines
where people are having parties
and going out without masks and stuff.
And I'm just here like,
yeah, this is just life.
- This is life, yeah.
- This is just life now for us, right.
- It's weird, 'cause it's like,
I know we spoke about this a lot before,
but it's because it's
such an ongoing thing
and it changes throughout the time.
It's like, all right, restaurants open.
All right, okay, cool.
But now they close at
8:00. All right, okay.
But now they can serve alcohol.
Okay, but now they can't.
It's like, wait, what's going on.
What the fuck is going on?
It's just, I'm so confused.
- The limit is three.
No, the limit is six.
The limit is four?
- And then it's like, all right.
And then Google Maps is
completely unreliable now
because now all the
opening and closing times
are a fucking lie.
It's totally dependent on the place
and whether they're doing it, and
most of the time, they're not the ones
updating their Google page.
So you don't even know
if shit's open or not.
- The only thing that
has stayed consistent
throughout this entire thing is comedy.
It's literally the only
thing that stayed consistent.
- Pretty much. I mean, you
want to go to a new place now,
you check out on Google Maps.
Oh, they're open.
You turn up at the door
and they're not open.
And then you try to find another place
and it's just kind of like
playing a roulette wheel
of just seeing what you can do.
'Cause it's,
lockdown here has been really weird.
'Cause we say lockdown,
but it's just like,
you can still go out and work.
You just can't really do
anything else but that.
I mean, the trains are still
fucking packed as shit.
- Oh yeah. If you get an
eight o'clock train, still,
you know, you're fucked.
You still get squeezed in.
There will be people
pushing you in, still,
during all of this.
And that's why a lot of the
experts say it's so worrying
in Tokyo because the density is insane.
You can't just social distance anywhere
in this fucking town.
And yeah, did you see that thing with the
Tokyo hotel or something,
where it was like,
the foreigners have to
get a different elevator
from the Japanese one?
- Yeah, yeah, I saw that.
I saw that.
- Classic Japanese xenophobia.
(Joey cheers)
- I heard that it was a misunderstanding.
I don't know if this is true.
- That's what they always fucking say.
- I heard this was a misunderstanding of,
it was supposed to be for people
who came from a foreign country.
- Right.
Even though, realistically, right now,
you're probably safer if you've
come from a foreign country.
- Yeah. I think that was a lot of the,
even though
some people were trying
to defend it, being like,
"No, no, they meant people who
just came in from America,"
or whatever, you know?
But a lot of people arguing.
Well, Japan has not
handled this very well.
I don't think they're in the
place to be able to, you know.
- I don't even think, what is it,
like less than 10% of the population's
got the vaccine, right?
- It's probably higher now
by the time this comes out.
- But I mean, still,
it's nowhere near where it should be,
considering the Olympics
is fucking starting.
- To me it just seems like,
why not just socially distance,
in general, in the elevator?
Why not just let two
people go in at a time
on the opposite end?
Why'd have to make it,
like the distinction?
Yeah, I dunno.
- I mean they could be--
That's too logical.
That's too logical for the Japanese--
- Japan is just a little,
you know the thing that sucks about Japan
is that they're just a little too quick
on the decision to make
it harsh on foreigners.
They're a little too comfortable
with making those rules.
- They're always--
- They're like a little too--
(Connor laughs)
- It's like, "Is something wrong?
It's the foreigners!"
- They're just a little,
it's just the speed at
which they'll be like,
"Oh, maybe we should just maybe
discriminate a little bit."
(all laugh)
- I'm feeling a little
discriminatory today.
- It's like that image of that guy
who falls off the bicycle.
And it's just like, "Oh,
it's the foreigners!"
- Damn foreigners!
- You know, the one time, you know, they,
people do try and justify it and all that.
But it's just the ease at
which sometimes Japan does it,
which bothers me the most.
Like we had that thing from the,
I think we did talk
about it on the podcast,
the Ibaraki Prefecture.
- I don't think we have talked about that.
- The Ibaraki Prefecture
gave a warning out
for people not to
interact with foreigners.
- That's right, yeah, I remember.
- That was one of their warnings.
"Don't interact with any foreigners."
I think, again, people defended,
some people defended it being like,
well they don't mean people
from a foreign country,
but there's no way for
Japanese people to be able to
distinguish between
a person who came from a
foreign country recently.
It was very obvious what
they were trying to say,
which was just stay away from foreigners.
You know, which,
it's a massive yikes.
- If this happened in
literally any other country,
they'd just be called out for it, right?
By everyone.
- I mean, luckily though, in a sense,
at least what I've seen on social media,
they have been called out.
That's why they're so quick
to retract and being like,
"Oh no, it was a misunderstanding."
- It was retracted very fast.
And I mean, you can imagine why.
It's supposed to be very, it's an--
The hotel is quite a,
what's it,
notable hotel.
- It's a big franchise.
- It's generally an expensive chain.
- Is it an expensive chain?
- Yeah, the Tokyo hotel is a very,
quite pricey.
- Oh, I thought it was just this really--
- It's a premium hotel.
And you know, normally for rich tourists.
- It's like if the Hilton
was like, "No Asians."
It's that level.
- It's, you know,
it's just sad.
Very sad.
I forgot what,
I was going to say something.
I had a really good point,
but I fucking forgot.
I'm dumb.
- Must have been a good point.
- It was such a riveting point,
but oh well, lost to time.
- I mean, it's just like, it's, you know,
obviously we're grateful to be here,
but it's just, it's weird that we,
it's not exactly that we
feel discriminated against,
obviously.
It's just sometimes there's
just a lot of little things
that we see and we feel,
and obviously hearing news like this,
it kind of adds to that, little by little.
- Yeah, I mean, when I
speak to someone my age,
I've never ever felt that in Japan at all.
I just feel that the government in,
almost in every country,
it's just older people
kind of out of touch.
- Yeah, I feel that's
the real problem here.
- I feel it's especially
prevalent in Japan
because, again, the older
population is, the majority.
- If it is, that's totally fine
because that's what the voters want.
- Literally all the voters are old.
- I mean, wasn't it like,
one of the people on
the Olympic committee,
just saying that women shouldn't--
- Women shouldn't talk? Yeah.
- Women shouldn't talk and
just stay in the kitchen
or something like that.
- It was something,
it was something along the lines of
women shouldn't be allowed
to talk at meetings
because they talked too long.
- Oh, that was it!
- At the Olympic meetings.
- And I'm like, that's
what dudes in the fifties
used to say to their wives.
- But that was the ex
prime minister of Japan.
- Was it?
- It was the,
he was the prime minister of
Japan, as far as I'm aware.
Can you Google it just to confirm that?
But as far as I know, it was
the ex prime minister of Japan,
which is just very telling.
And I'm not saying, you
know, the UK is much better,
we're fucking awful with that shit.
But again, they're very quick
to get called out by it.
But then people calling
out the Japanese government
for a lot of the stuff, you know,
a lot of the time it is the
younger people who are doing it.
- The social media generation.
- Yeah, it was the ex
prime minister of Japan.
- [Navi] Yoshiro Mori.
- Oh, Mori Yoshiro, yeah, yeah.
- But he's also like, what
91, years old or something?
And he's the fucking--
- I'm not being funny,
but no one 91 years old
should be making countrywide decisions.
I think at that point you
are just so far out of touch
with the country.
- Absolutely.
- You can't.
- Yeah, I mean, it's
just like, at that point,
you don't really, I mean,
you're 91, right?
Why would you care to change for society?
Because, you know,
at that point, you
already know who you are.
You're not going to put
in the effort to change.
And it's just,
yeah, at that point,
you probably shouldn't be
running a country, you know.
- I'm like, should it be at 70 something?
But then, Bernie makes
me always think like,
damn, okay, maybe old people,
maybe they know what's up.
- Oh, yeah, I completely forgot.
(Garnt laughs)
- I guess this is our
political, my political--
(all laugh)
- Shit.
- Fucking too political on the show.
- This is probably the most political
we've ever gotten on the show.
- What, just naming politicians?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
He said the name!
- It's one of those things
where it's like, I don't know.
It's just,
they're a little too comfortable
with dishing that shit out.
- Whenever I hear stories
like that, there's
a part of me that hears that
kind of stuff happening,
and just makes me wish
that young people in Japan
were a little more politically interested.
- Yeah, they pretty much have no interest
or even if they do, they
don't talk about it publicly.
- No, no. No one talks about it publicly.
Barely anyone has any interest.
No one believes in the government here.
They're just like,
"Yeah, whatever. They're
just doing their thing.
As long as we're not in a war
with another country, we good.
- The consensus seems to be,
from when I've spoke to people,
is that they're like, "Oh, I don't care.
As long as they don't ruin my life."
- There's a lot of young people
who don't even know who
the prime minister is.
- Wow.
- It just goes to show
they're that out of touch.
- But in Japan, you don't get
to choose the prime minister.
- No.
- You choose the party.
And then they choose the prime minister.
Whereas, you know,
I think that's technically
the same in the UK,
but it's not done like that at all.
We're promised who the
person is when we're voting.
And that's how it is.
But in Japan, you vote for the party
and you don't get a say who they pick.
- But, again, it's like,
I've talked to young people,
you know,
some same age, a little bit
older, a little bit younger.
And there's a lot of
them who don't even know
what the political parties
are or what they do.
They're just not interested
in it whatsoever.
And it's like--
- I kind of get the vibe
that everyone is just like
so overworked.
They don't have time to care.
- It's the last thing
they wanna worry about.
- That's pretty much
the vibe I get, is like
everyone's just fucking fighting
for their life as it is.
Everyone's just trying
to get through the day.
They don't have time to
care about other issues,
a lot of the time.
- I remember when they
raised the GST from 8% to 10%
and there was all these mobs.
- I saw that.
- All these mobs of all
these old people being like,
"How fucking dare you?"
Meanwhile, the young people are like,
"Understandable, have a nice
day, I'll just work harder."
It's like, they just don't care.
It's like, "Oh, they made a new law?
Sick. I guess I'm just gonna have to
mold my life around this new law, now.
- Speaking of dumb Japanese laws,
you can be arrested in
Japan if you mod games,
like save files.
- Yeah, that sounds about right.
- Can you actually?
- A guy in--
- The Skyrim community
are sweating right now.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- A guy in Nagano, I think,
was arrested and fined 65,000 pounds,
about $100K in dollars,
for selling Breath of the Wild
save files that were modded.
- Seriously?
- Yeah, no joke.
And apparently, like I've read about it.
Apparently, one of the main
reasons why this law was passed
was because,
guess which company pushed for it.
- Nintendo.
- Yeah!
- Of course they did.
- But obviously they tried,
obviously that shit just,
America's like, "LMAO, no."
They're not passing that law in America
because you have the right
to do whatever you want
with the products you buy.
But yeah, Nintendo somehow
managed to push for a law.
- To be fair, I think the
selling part was the problem.
If you just put it online--
- But it's also illegal to
even mod a Switch in Japan.
You can't mod a Switch in Japan.
- But I think it was
extra bad for the dude
because he sold it for money.
- I mean, isn't it technically illegal
everywhere to mod a Switch?
- No, no, no.
So, in the U.S.,
it's counted as you bought a product,
and you're allowed to do whatever you want
with that product.
You can do whatever you want.
- So what's the illegal part, then?
Buying the games, getting the games?
- Apparently.
So I think the way they've
managed to pass the law is that
it's still an ongoing
thing, like a service.
You don't actually own the game.
You own a copy of the game.
And by changing it, you're
ruining or infringing--
- If you buy a Nintendo
product, Nintendo owns you.
There is no escape.
- Didn't Apple try--
I don't know if it's illegal, again,
can you check it if it's
illegal to jailbreak your phone?
I can't remember.
I'm pretty sure it's not--
- I think it is illegal.
- I think it is.
- In every country?
- I don't know. Is it, or
does it just break warranty?
- I thought it just
broke warranty in the UK.
I can't remember though.
- [Man] It definitely at
least breaks warranty.
- I know that.
- Everyone knows that.
- Generally, you're allowed
to do what the fuck you want
with the stuff you own.
- I've never hard of
anyone getting arrested
for jailbreaking their phone.
- Just the idea of a raid
going on into some guy's house.
Like, "Get down! Stop! Drop
the Legend of Zelda copies!
Put them on the floor!"
You know, in Japan,
The thing is in Japan, right--
- Boys walk up with hazmat suits.
- When they arrest people in Japan,
they don't arrest you with two people.
They send like twenty fucking
police officers, in Japan,
when they arrest you.
- The send the boys down, man.
They got the whole squad coming.
- [Navi] Overall, it's breaking
your iPhone's warranty.
The legality, I think it
differs between the country.
But in terms of Apple,
it's like, you don't get--
- No, no, no, yeah.
They're not gonna fucking
sue you for doing it.
- [Navi] So, it's just
your warranty's gone.
- I mean, that's understandable.
- Most products do that.
Like, "Hey, if you change this thing,
we're not gonna fix it for you."
- If you break the seal that says,
"Breaking the seal breaks the warranty,"
then generally, that
breaks the warranty, right?
- Yeah, but then I feel, you know,
you also have to understand that Japan
is falling a little bit short
on most common sense laws,
like Fair Use, for example.
- Fair Use just isn't a thing here,
as we've found out many times.
- Just seeing all these
videos of Nintendo fans
pleading with Nintendo
to change their mind.
And then, after living
here, I'm like, dude, it's--
- It's not gonna happen.
- That's not how it rolls.
It's like, us pleading with Nintendo
is not gonna fucking do
anything unless you're--
- We should start a Kickstarter
to get them to change the laws!
- Unless you are fully
100% Japanese and in that
boardroom meeting with
them, isn't going to matter.
- Unless you're Shigeru
Miyamoto, it's not gonna change.
- Yeah, definitely coming to live here
and seeing how it works on the inside,
I'm just like, yeah, it's a lot of,
no matter how much noise
gets made on Twitter,
I think most of the time it's
going to fall on deaf ears.
- Yeah, so the way that
I've come to realize,
at least from living here,
you can say anything
you want over an email.
You can explain everything
as well as you want
through a different person.
But unless there is a
Japanese guy there in the room
at the board meeting,
explaining something
directly to the person,
it will not get changed.
- You can't have a Zoom call,
you can't send an email,
you can't send an angry tweet.
You know, you could fucking
ratio the shit out of Nintendo,
they'll be like, "I don't give a shit."
You need to have someone there
explaining to the person,
in person, speaking fluent Japanese,
and possibly having a Japanese passport,
before they take anything seriously.
- Even then it's like, "Oh, so
what company do you work for?
Who are your backers? Who
are you representing?"
- I've worked at places where
I've wanted to shoot there,
And I've had a friend tell
them, who wasn't Japanese,
"Hey, can we shoot
there? And they're like,
"No, I don't know about it."
But then you have a Japanese
person do the exact same thing,
like if Kaho hits them up and is like,
"Hey, this is what we're doing."
And they're like, "Oh, okay, sure."
It's like, what?
It's just they don't believe you.
They think you're lying
'cause you're not Japanese.
Like you don't understand. You
don't understand how I think.
- These sneaky foreigners
trying to get around our ways.
- It's bizarre. It's really strange.
But that's just the way that it's,
businesses is done here.
And it's, you know,
it makes so much sense now
why these companies do this
fucking stupid shit.
I'm like, oh, I totally get it now.
- And I'm kind of like sitting
in that halfway point, right?
'Cause if I don't open
my mouth, they'll be like
"This fucking foreigner
tryna get around me."
The moment I open my mouth, they're like,
"Oh, you're Nihongo? Nihongo Jouzu?
All right, let's do it, boys."
- All right, let's do business, right?
- Exactly. I rock up, let's do business.
"No, you're a foreigner."
JK, I am Nihongo Jouzu actually.
And they're like, "All right, I'm sorry.
All right. Let's do some business."
I'm like, it's so fucking embarrassing.
- Yeah. And I feel like companies
in Japan are very, very,
what's the word?
They very much stick to
the hierarchy of decisions.
And if you're not
the same level, you can't comment.
- Are you talking about the pyramid?
- The pyramid scheme.
- Well, if you're not in that meeting,
your opinion doesn't matter
no matter who you talk to.
So I feel like when people
are like, all right,
even if like, I don't know,
because Nintendo has
a Nintendo of America.
I'd love to know how
much Nintendo of America
has a say over what
Nintendo, the Japan office,
I feel like--
- Probably not a lot.
I feel like people would,
yeah, I think it's probably not a lot.
Just based off like what I've
seen from other companies here
where you would think that
they would have an input,
but they don't.
- Doug Bowser is like,
"So can we change this thing?"
And they're like, "But
we're in a Zoom call.
You're not in the office.
So, I don't know about that."
- Again, it's all speculation,
but I imagine it's, if any,
from what I've seen here,
it's very difficult to get things done
if you're not the same level.
- Basically, the longer I live in Japan,
the more respect I have
for Suzaku in Code Geass.
'Cause you watch Code Geass
and everyone wants to
be the Lelouch, right.
Everyone wants to be the fucking Lelouch.
Bring down the system,
fuck the corporations.
But then I'm just like,
yo, Suzaku's out there
working his fucking ass off
to change shit, man.
He's the real one. He's the real one.
- He's climbing that pyramid, boys.
- He's climbing the hierarchy, man.
- If this was IRL, Suzaku would
still be a fucking grunt--
(Garnt laughs)
He's like, "Well, what
do you mean, you're 22?
No permission for you."
- "Do you have work experience?
Then stay the fuck down."
- "Oh, you're an honorary Britannian?
No, no. What the fuck is
an honorary Britannian?
You're not one of the--"
- Oh, yeah, he wasn't even one of them.
There's no way he could pass. No, no, no.
He's the guy who changes
the vending machines.
Come on, they wouldn't let him.
Garnt had to pee, so we're back.
What have you been up to,
Garnt? How was your pee?
- It was great, it was great.
I mean, speaking about the
rest of the world healing,
it's getting to the point
now where I kind of meet
lots of people that are
planning their journeys home.
And that includes us as well.
Or me and Connor, at least.
- Yeah, you two are.
- You know what I was
missing the other day?
And I know I must be fucking mental.
- What?
- I was missing a pub.
- What's wrong with that?
Pubs are great.
- I've talked about how--
- But I mean, Garnt's talked
about how he doesn't like pubs.
- I've talked about how pubs are--
- But Garnt's a fucking idiot.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I mean, Garnt thinks the
architecture here is great.
Garnt is a fake British person.
- Maybe.
- Yeah, he's Thai.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I'm an honorary Britannian.
(all laugh)
- You got him there.
- I guess so.
- Got em!
- Got got.
- Came full circle.
- But, yeah, I just had
this overwhelming urge
to go to a fucking
Wetherspoons, and I'm just like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
- Every week you should get that urge.
(Joey snorts)
The moment Friday takes over, you're like,
"Fuck, I want the Curry Club and a pint."
It's great. You can get like a Curry,
a whole Curry meal
and a full pint of your alcohol of choice,
like 10 bucks.
- And then Fridays is fish
and chips Fridays as well.
- You know it is! You know it is!
(Garnt laughs)
- "Now you're speaking my language!"
- Yeah, I don't know,
now that we are in the
process of being able
to go back to our
countries, it's just like,
it feels good, and it feels like
I get to kind of look forward
to all the things that
have made me feel kind
of homesick, I think.
Cause I didn't think I would
feel too homesick about England
until I kind of moved out of it
and couldn't go back for a while.
- I think this lockdown
or pandemic has definitely
proven to people that like,
"Oh, maybe I am homesick."
Just give me enough time
before you're homesick.
- First year, I was like, it's
all right, it's not that bad.
I was like, oh, okay,
I can get used to this.
Then now I'm just going insane.
Now I'm like, nothing is open,
I can't fucking do anything.
Can't film any cool videos half the time.
Every single thing is like boring shit.
And then now I can't, I don't know.
So we're booking a trip home.
I don't even know what
the fuck is happening
because every country
keeps changing its mind
on what's happening.
So I'm like, wait, do
I book the hotel for,
how many days is lockdown?
When will they get rid of it?
Are you? Are you getting rid of it?
Tell me if you're getting rid
of it. I would like to know.
So it's really difficult right now.
- Isn't home quarantine an option though?
- Yeah, in the UK, yeah.
You can quarantine in your
own home or in a hotel.
And then Japan might
be doing or is doing--
- Vaccine passports.
- I think that's to
return to Japan, I think.
- Yeah, to return to Japan.
- Which apparently, you
could apply from the 26th,
my birthday, woo.
- The ultimate birthday present.
- Which is when we get
our second dose as well.
So yeah, I don't know what's happening.
I guess I'll figure it out.
- What's the first
thing you're going to do
when you go back to England?
- That's what I was going to ask as well.
- Pub?
- I am going straight to the fucking pub.
- Check into the hotel, I guess?
I mean that's the practical answer, right?
- But after that.
After you've settled
down at the hotel room,
what's the first thing you want to go to?
Tesco's?
- Tesco's meal deal.
- Actually, I want a fucking meal deal.
They'll probably have one at the airport.
So I'll probably get a
meal deal at the airport.
Tesco's meal deal, banging.
Three pound, fuck, dude.
Choice of my favorite sandwich fillings.
- But if it's the airport,
it's probably like seven pound.
- I guess it's like four.
- It's just gonna be so weird
going to a shop or a Tesco's.
- I genuinely miss airports.
I miss going to an airport.
- I miss--
- Just chilling at the
airport waiting for my flight.
You get to watch so much
shit when you're on a flight.
I've haven't been able
to watch TV in so long,
'cause I haven't been on a flight.
You know what I mean?
You get so much watching
done when you're on a plane.
I'm chilling in the
lobby, having a coffee.
When you finally you've checked in,
your bags are in the thing,
it's actually kind of chill,
that hour before your flight.
- I like the feeling of
going on a long haul flight,
just knowing--
'Cause it kind of like,
aside from the long
haul part of the flight,
I just like the feeling of knowing,
it feels like I'm going on a holiday.
It feels like I'm going away for a while.
And it's, there's
something about going to,
to the airport of your home country.
It just feels like,
you know, mum's cooking
or something like that.
It just feels, I don't know.
It just, there's something about it.
- I know what you mean, yeah.
- Because every time I go visit Thailand
and I step out and I see the Thai airport,
I'm just like, oh, I'm
getting all nostalgic
and it's just the fucking airport.
It smells different.
- There's some guy shouting at you.
- No, no, no. Every
country smells different.
And I don't know why it is.
- I totally get that.
- But I literally step out
of the airport, go to the,
the Thai airport has this certain smell,
Gatwick and Heathrow
has this certain smell.
And I'm just like, I can't
describe what it is, but I just,
(Garnt laughs)
but it just feels comforting.
And I didn't know that
airports smell different
until you go off the
airplane and you're like,
damn, I recognize this.
- "I recognize this."
- I dunno if this is the
talk of a madman right now.
- No, no, I get that whole smell thing.
- Yeah, I don't.
(all laugh)
- It's like when certain smells
trigger certain memories.
- I just feel like it's the
breathability of the country,
you know, like some--
- That makes less sense.
(Garnt laughs)
- Because when you land in Japan,
depending on which airport
you land, the air is stuffy.
- When I landed in San
Francisco, I was like,
"Fuck, this air sucks."
I'm breathing it in, I'm like,
"Oh my God, the pollution."
- You're literally just
saying the same thing
as what he said but just rephrased.
- No, he said smells. I'm
like, pollution level.
Like Tokyo--
- How can you tell the pollution levels?
- Well, when you breathe in.
Can you not breathe the
quality of air? You can't tell?
- I can, but--
- Yeah, but I can't do it at
different fucking airports.
- I can.
- What are you, a fucking bloodhound?
- When I land in the fucking country,
I step off the plane,
I take a deep breath,
and I'm like, this air's shit.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Why is this insane?
- He called me the fucking insane one.
- You literally breathe
the air and you're like,
this air is polluted.
- It literally sounds like
the stupidest superpower.
- When I went to--
- I can tell pollution
levels in the air I breathe.
- LA has horrible air,
and San Francisco had--
- Most big cities have horrible air.
- Depends.
- That's what makes up the city.
- I can't tell the air pollution
differing from most cities.
I mean, for example,
there's a difference
between Bangkok and London,
- Tokyo's awful.
Tokyo's air is horrible.
- Tokyo's fine. It's fine.
What are you talking about?
- You don't know 'cause
you've been here too long.
- What are you talking about?
Tokyo's fine.
- It is not. It tastes like shit.
When I breathe it in,
I don't like the smell.
I don't like the taste.
- [Navi] Jakarta is horrible.
- Anywhere in Southeast Asia is horrible.
- Literally go to anywhere in
Southeast Asia, go to China.
- You're not selling me on it.
- [Man] Singapore is fine, though.
- Yo, fuck off.
- Singapore is not fine.
- You're literally
surrounded by countries.
- I landed in Singapore Airport
and I was like, this is
a really pretty airport.
God, it smells like shit, though.
- That's why the airport
has so much plants.
With the first breath, it lies to you.
So you think, oh, it's actually good.
Then you leave the plant fucking--
'Cause I've seen their airport.
It's just full of plants
and shit. That's why.
- It's a really pretty airport.
- Out of every airport I've been to,
Singapore Airport is by far
the best fucking airport.
- A hundred percent.
And I have no idea why
the Singaporean Airport--
- You know which country
has the best tasting air
upon landing in my experience so far?
Amsterdam had the best air.
When I got off that plane, I was like,
damn, this is some clean air.
- Yeah, I can agree with that.
- See, even you can agree.
When I got in Charles de Gaulle in Paris,
I was like, put me back
on the fucking plane.
Get me outta here. It's
bad enough I'm in Paris,
let alone having to
fucking breathe this air.
- I was like that when I landed in JFK.
- Oh, my God.
- In New York, I was like--
(Joey retches)
- The New York air, you're like, "Bruh."
I don't even need studies to
tell me this air is polluted.
This is what I'm saying!
You can tell, when you get
off the plane, you breathe,
you're like, ooh, this is rough.
- Yeah, but that's the same logic
as what Garnt was saying about--
- No, he was saying smell.
- It smells different to me.
Maybe it's the same thing.
- You're always biased
about your hometown airport.
You're always biased.
- I think that--
- I guarantee people living
in New York from New York
is like, JFK has the best smelling airport
because it smells like home. Guaranteed.
- Maybe I just don't
know what fresh air is,
'cause I'm a city boy.
- I was saying to Garnt
when I get the train
from London to Wales, like
when I step off the train,
when the train opens and I
breathe in Wales, I'm like,
holy shit, this is what
actual air tastes like.
- That's because you're
from there, though.
- I'm like, whoa.
- So there's probably a bias.
- It's not like super industrial.
There's just fucking fields everywhere.
- Me and Connor were walking to the office
and Connor was like, "God,
this air tastes horrible."
And I'm just like, Connor, what the fuck?
Tokyo air is great. I don't
know what you're talking about.
- What are you on about?
It's like a mega city, bro.
The air is fucked here.
- For a city, the Tokyo air is
actually pretty good, I feel.
- Could that possibly be
the most wankerish thing
that Connor has ever said?
"Oh, the air tastes horrible
here. Get this outta my face."
- I'm just saying, it tastes polluted.
- That could probably be
the most privileged thing
you could have said in your life.
- "My air is better than yours."
- "My air is better."
- Bring me my fresh air,
canister, won't you?
- Connor's mum comes to visit from Wales
and she just brings like a jar of air.
She's like, "Connor, breathe this in."
What did Meilyne write? Did
she write "incest" again?
- She's giving me the air quality.
What is this? Is this the rating?
- Higher is better?
- [Meilyne] Lower is better.
- That's bullshit, there's no way.
- Let me see this, let me see this.
- Also, Rhyl is terrible.
- So, air quality index.
So, the higher it is,
the more polluted it is.
Amsterdam, 69. Nice.
(all laugh)
San Fran is 31.
- I hate the fact that we've
got the whole fucking office
to laugh at the number 69.
- You know it.
San Fran air quality index is 31.
And then Wales is 68.
- This is Rhyl. Doesn't count.
Rhyl's a shithole.
- So basically, what
Meilyne is saying is that
San Fran air quality is
twice as better as Wales.
- That's fucking biased as fuck.
Meilyne's from San Francisco.
That's why Meilyne pulled that shit out.
- She just came up with a random number.
- No fucking way.
- She's like,
"Facts don't care about
your feelings, Connor."
- Maybe they took that out
in some vineyard somewhere,
where there's perfect air, but
that city is fucking awful.
- Your nostrils are dirty.
(all laugh)
- Connor's got those
dirty Welshmen nostrils.
- If you're born and raised in the city,
your nostril hair is longer.
(Joey laughs)
Did you know that?
Google it, Google it.
- Where'd you get this piece of--
- On the next episode of Scientology.
- Because your nostrils
need to filter more shit,
so it naturally just grows longer.
- I get that, but where
the fuck did you read that?
- I don't know, I just heard it.
I read it somewhere.
(Garnt laughs)
It's true. Look it up. Google it.
- I mean, I believe the logic
because it's just like--
- That's why Meilyne has
these massive bushes going on.
(all laugh)
She's gonna kill me.
I'm going to get a
death threat after this.
While Navi looks it up,
it's true. But, yeah.
I don't know why I heard about that.
- I dunno, man.
- [Navi] There is a research about it.
- Is there actually research about this?
- Called "How Climate
Helped Shape Your Nose."
- Well, yeah, no, I get
that, but nose hairs?
- Type in what I said.
- Nostril hair, I'm still searching.
- Type in "nostril hair length,
(Garnt laughs)
correlation city."
- I feel sorry for the person
who actually did a full-on study on this.
Who woke up one day and was just like,
"You know what? I want to
measure nostril hair length."
- "My friend's nose hairs
are longer than mine.
There has to be a reason behind that."
- We need to know these things.
We don't know enough about the human body.
We need to know everything.
So we can just tell what
the fuck's going on.
- I mean, is this like
when you were talking about
fucking mouth breathers and all that shit?
- Mouth breathers having no chin.
- I don't know if this is
one of those lies or not.
It could be.
But, in my head, it's one of
those things where I'm like,
I don't even care if this
is bullshit, it makes sense.
- Weren't you scared? Because
you were going to the dentist
to get not retainers, but the--
- The mouth guard.
- The mouth guard thing.
And you were just like,
"I don't want to breathe--"
- Generally, it's better to breathe
through your nose, anyway,
just for air quality.
- Especially when it has to filter
through all those nose hairs.
- It has to fucking filter through.
- All right, Navi.
- All right, Navi, what is it?
- Well, there is a study in like,
but it's a very old article.
- "Study," he says.
- There is a study on Tumblr.
- I could be chatting out
of my ass for all I know.
- I feel like you are, Connor.
- If there are any nose
hair experts watching this,
could you leave it down in the
comments, please? Thank you.
- [Navi] "The Nose Hair
Indicator for Air Pollution."
(Joey laughs)
- That sounds like an Onion article.
That doesn't sound real.
- [Navi] I know, it doesn't sound real.
- The nose hair--
- It would make sense, though, right?
If you were born in a place
that was more polluted,
naturally, it would make sense
that your body would want--
- I feel like that's something
your mum says to be like,
"It's a good thing you're
not in the city, right?
They have long nose hairs
in the city, Connor."
- "You don't have to trim
your nose hairs, boy."
- It's like a wives' tale.
- I always felt like I had
a long nose hair anyway.
So I'm like, fuck, imagine
if I was born in the city.
I'd have Tarzan's crotch in my nose.
- [Navi] So, interactive
indicator of poor air quality
using nose hair length as a rough metric
for just how much nasal
fiber one would need to catch
and filter harmful particulate
matter in ages over 10.
- That sounds like I'm right.
(Navi laughs)
- [Navi] But it sounds ridiculous, though.
- I literally stopped listening
halfway through that sentence.
Did you get that off WikiHow?
- Also, I don't know why,
I started getting recommended videos about
breathing from your mouth
and I dunno why I was getting
recommended this stuff,
but I watched it.
- "Watched by other mouthbreathers."
(all laugh)
- I watched it, and it was like,
it was one of those videos
where it's like, this is,
this would be,
if I wasn't dumb as fuck,
this would be so convincing.
It felt so manipulative, these videos.
They were like, "Look, there's twins.
One of them was allergic to hamsters
and they had a hamster in their room.
And thus he couldn't
breathe through his nose
and look what happened to
his chin. It's all gross."
- What, they just showed
a fucking picture of Leafy
or something like that?
- Why you gotta do him like that, man?
That's bullying, bro.
We'll get demonetized.
- One of them is Leafy and the
other guy is like chin dude.
- It was like one had
a clearly defined chin.
- It's like buff as shit Chad.
- One had a clearly defined chin
and one had the, I don't
even know what you call it,
It's not really a chin.
It kind of like leads into it.
And that's generally
believed to be unattractive
amongst Sigma male people.
(all laugh)
- I love that as well.
- It's where your chin is
getting swollen into your neck.
- Kinda, yeah.
And it's one of those things
where you're like, huh,
everyone I did meet who I feel
like had that kind of face,
did breathe through their mouth, I think.
And then it's one of those
things where it kind of,
it builds on your ignorance of it
and your anecdotal evidence of it.
But then I, you know,
I saw more videos about it
and I was like, you know,
the more I feel like it,
the more this is like,
feels like some kind
of Sigma male bullshit.
You know what I mean? I
felt like I was getting fed,
but I don't know how accurate it is.
Because then I start watching videos about
apparently doctors who specialize in,
what they'll do is, they'll,
fuck what do they do?
They'll do something
so that when you sleep,
when you normally do it,
that you breathe through your mouth
and they'll go, "Look, it's fixed.
His chin is fucking normal."
- What, they're just
like, "Here's some tape.
Put it on your mouth while you sleep."
- It was one of those things--
- His chin is normal.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I didn't particularly
care to learn more about it
or check how real it was.
- But now it's in your head.
And now you're just
like, "But what if I do
breathe through my nose?"
- I generally want to breathe
through my nose anyway,
because it's just the whole of, you know,
when you breathe through your mouth,
it isn't being filtered and shit.
I'd like to live as long as I can,
so I can be as stubborn as
I can for as long as I can.
Maybe I can become a Japanese politician
and make life hell for
all the young people.
Full circle, baby.
- I mean, I feel like you do breathe
through your nose most of the time.
You can only tell who
the mouth breathers are,
because--
(Garnt laughs)
No, no, no. Let me finish my sentence.
You can only tell who the mouth
breathers are when you like,
you're in a hotel room.
And there's always the one
snorer who is just like,
you know sometimes when
you're bunking with--
- I snore sometimes.
- Sometimes. When you're really tired,
but sometimes you are
with a group of mates
and you know who the
fucking snorer is, right.
And it's like a fucking
time limit of just like,
"All right, I've got literally
half an hour to fall asleep
or I'm not sleeping tonight."
- And it's not just the snorers, right?
Because there are the snores
that do it through their nose
and then there's the snorers
that do it through their mouth.
- Oh, you can tell when people
snore through their mouth.
- Yeah, exactly.
- No, it's so weird,
'cause I grew up breathing
through my mouth.
So I was a mouth breather
when I would sleep,
when I was a kid.
But that's because I had
like horrible hay fever,
so my nose was constantly
blocked all the time.
So I literally used to sleep--
- It sounds like a lowkey insult.
It's like, "I knew you were a
fucking mouth breather, Joey."
- It is. It's used as an insult.
- Is it?
- It's used as predominantly an insult.
- A fucking mouth breather.
- Because it's--
- By who?
- A lot of people use it as an insult.
- Not me.
- It's a pretty good descriptive insult
because I feel like, you know,
as much as I wouldn't use it,
you get a very good picture of
what they're trying to paint,
when someone calls you a mouth breather.
(Garnt laughs)
- It sounds funny, I don't know.
- You fucking mouth breather.
- Fucking mouth breather, God damn it.
- And I just became,
for a little bit, I
definitely became paranoid
that I was breathing through my mouth.
- Am I becoming a mouth breather?
- I remember that stage.
- I'd be like, oh my God, my
breathing's off 10 seconds.
My fucking chin.
(Garnt laughs)
But then, because I feel like
I have a semi-defined chin,
I guess. I don't know.
- Semi-defined chin.
- I haven't got this Chad level--
- You have a nose breather chin.
- And I was like, yeah, I
did breathe through my nose
as a kid, so it makes sense.
But then again,
I feel like it all goes
on anecdotal evidence,
you know, everything.
I don't know how accurate it is.
it felt like pseudoscience
when I was watching this shit.
- Pretty much.
- It was enough to make me care,
even though I know I shouldn't.
- Now you've made a lot
of people self-conscious.
Everyone watching this is gonna be like,
"Oh shit, do I breathe through my mouth?"
- 90% of people are just doing this like,
"Do I have a chin? Am I good? Am I good?"
- Isn't it sad that we
give a shit about chins?
I don't care about chins.
- Why do we care about chins?
- Dunno.
- Did your parents ever
tell you an old folk tale
or something to get you
to do something as a kid?
- Oh, yeah, all the time.
- I dunno,
I dunno what Japanese things there are
because in Thailand, it's like,
one of the things is
if you eat on the bed,
then you'll get,
when you reincarnate in your next life,
you're gonna reincarnate as a snake.
And I'm just remembering this now.
- That sounds epic!
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I'm down, sign me up.
- And that was what I was told
to not get me to eat on the bed.
And I don't,
I guess it worked because I
hate eating on the bed now.
- Japan is infamous for all
these Proverbs and wives' tales.
One of them was like,
if you sleep immediately after you eat,
then you turn into a cow.
- I think Thailand had something
similar to that as well.
- I guess.
- I think my mum stopped telling me these
because whenever my mum told me them,
I would immediately go and try them.
(Garnt laughs)
- I just, as a kid,
I just never believed
anything people told me.
When people would be like,
don't walk under ladders or some shit,
'cause apparently it's
superstitious, right?
I think it's a safety issue.
- Or a black cat walking past, right?
- I would just go and do all those things.
I'd be like, I don't,
I remember one time my mum was like,
"What the fuck are you doing?"
I just kept opening the umbrella in doors.
I was like, I want to see
if something bad happens.
So I just kept opening it indoors.
- In Japan as well, there's that.
- And nothing happened. I was like, oh.
- Well, that's the thing.
It's like, some Japanese
Proverbs are based on
actual facts that are
harmful to your body.
So the sleeping after
you eat thing is actually
has a little bit of logic to it.
Because if you do sleep
immediately after you eat,
then all the gastric stuff
goes up your esophagus and it--
- Why'd it make me so damn sleepy?
- Burns your esophagus
and damages your throat.
So I'm like, oh, okay.
So, there's actual reasoning
behind that, that's cool.
But then there are some which just like,
are like,
don't whistle at night
because snakes will come.
And I'm like, snakes are literally deaf.
- Bro, that sounds amazing.
We got a snake army.
- They have no ears.
- Snake army.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- How snake charmers,
it isn't from the music,
it's from the movement.
- From the vibrations.
- No, the movements.
- It's literally the movement of this.
- The movement of the
guy that they follow.
- How did snake charmers start?
(Joey laughs)
- They just wake up one
day and they're like,
"You know what? I wanna charm some snakes.
I got a flute. I got a basket."
- White people are stupid.
I don't know.
- Do snake charmers even exist anymore?
- You don't really charm them, do you?
You just make them dance a little bit.
- Right, but is that a thing that's like,
is there a person out there
somewhere in the world
that's like, "Yes, I am a
professional snake charmer."
- Probably.
- It's probably a mouth breather.
(Joey laughs)
- Why, why? You're obsessed
with that word now.
- Now that you've told me it's an insult--
- All snake charmers are mouth breathers.
- If there's fucking psychics out there,
there can be any job, I
don't really give a fuck.
- I just feel, though,
it's one of those pseudo
occupations that were kind of
very timely back in the day.
It's like, you know, a soothsayer, right?
No one goes around being like,
"I'm a professional soothsayer."
- What's a soothsayer?
- They're just like budget magicians.
Yeah, what is that, actually?
- A soothsayer is a person who goes around
and tells fortunes and
tells your future and stuff.
- Oh, that's a load of shit.
- You mean, like a fortune teller?
- Kind of, yeah.
- That's an occupation that shouldn't--
- But soothsayer sounds way cooler.
- That's an occupation that should have
gone out of business.
- I think it did go out of business.
- No, fortune telling.
- Oh, fortune telling.
- How that shit still exists, I dunno.
I have friends who do
that and I'm just like,
you're a fucking idiot.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- With like what, the crystal
ball or the tarot cards or?
- They'll read their hands and stuff.
- Oh!
- Oh, palm reading.
- Yeah, I'm like,
have you seen some of the fish out there?
Do you think God really
gave enough of a fuck
to worry about putting
inscriptions on your hand
of what your life's going to be like?
Man couldn't even finish half the fucking
fishes in the ocean.
Are you serious, bro? Like, come on.
No, no, he did not inscribe,
he doesn't give a fuck about you.
- I mean, I like doing
it every now and then
just to see what they say.
- We like to feel interesting as people.
That's an egotistical need that we have.
But I genuinely believe that
we are not interesting things.
It is up to us to make
our own lives interesting.
And horoscopes and all
that and all that nonsense,
I just don't believe in any of it.
'Cause I'm like, nobody
gives a fuck about this.
- You don't believe in star
signs or anything like that?
- No.
- Honestly, I don't.
- Yeah, me either.
(Garnt laughs)
- Anyway.
- Yeah, me either. Anyway.
- The whole blood type, the
whole lines on your hands.
All of that shit, I just
think it's fucking nonsense.
I think it's cool.
And when someone tells me, I'll listen.
- I think it's cool for
the sake of entertainment.
- I view it as more of
just an entertainment thing
or like a conversation starter, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not something I take seriously.
- But I'm like, is your
life is so fucking boring,
where this is the stuff
that gets you excited?
This is what you look forward to?
You need lies to tell yourself
to feel like you're
doing something in life?
Just go and fucking do something.
- Some people need that, man.
Some people need that encouragement.
- Stop. Go and do something.
Stop reading your fucking hands.
- Only mouth breathers do that.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- The reason why you have
no chin is not because
of a line in your hand, okay?
- It's because you breathe
through your mouth.
- Connor's like, "Fuck reading your hands,
but please breathe through
your mouth. That's real."
- I think that there's
behavior that you can do
that can affect your health
and your body, right?
That's, I feel like that's fair to say.
- I mean, I feel--
- But I think that no mystical entity
decided to carve some
fucking lines in your hand,
and that would decide how your
personality was going to be.
No, fuck no.
- I mean, yeah, there
is a clear difference.
Because I feel like there
is a lot of little things
you just don't know about your body
and then you don't figure
it out until you hit like 30
or something.
And then you realize, oh--
- We also don't know a lot of the stuff
about the human body.
We're still barely understanding
how the mind works,
you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, we're still fucking
decades or centuries off
to figuring out how that works.
- I mean, all of America
doesn't even have bidets.
So how the fuck are they gonna have
scientific breakthroughs?
- I can't believe it.
- You can't have a
scientific breakthrough,
not with a bidet.
- They call themselves
a first world country.
Not having any bidets.
If they haven't figured that out,
how the fuck are they going to figure out
what's going on in the brain?
Sorry, go ahead, Garnt.
- I completely forgot--
- You were talking about
how they haven't discovered
anything about the brain.
- No, it's just like,
part of growing up and growing
into your thirties, I guess,
is just realizing that sometimes,
you just have a problem with your body.
And like, as a kid, I
thought everything's fixable.
Everything will go back
to normal, eventually.
And then you don't realize that
sometimes you just have a problem
and then you just learn to live with it.
It's sad.
- You just kinda hope that
you don't get a problem
that's too insufferable.
- Life-threatening, yeah.
- Like kidney stones.
Fuck, if I get those, fuck.
- Everyone around my age
just starts talking about their knees.
And luckily enough,
I haven't felt anything
about my knees yet.
- It's like lower back pain,
knees, neck pain, headaches.
- It's just like God decided,
all right, everyone gets a debuff at 30.
Everyone gets a different one, you know.
- It's like the moment you turn 30,
God comes to your sleep and
just clocks you in the knees.
It's like, "You're 30 now!"
Yeah. I don't know.
I watched that video of, what was it?
It was probably on your guys
recommended as well of like,
how do kidney stones--
- I was just going to watch that.
I had it on the "Watch
Later," I never did.
- A super interesting
video, I recommend it.
But it's like--
- Explain it to me.
- Basically, it's this guy who,
he got big off Tiktok, I think,
because he's like a,
he works in forensics or something.
But basically he uses the
bodies that, you know,
you donate to science
and to study things about
the human body, basically.
And this guy got really big on Tiktok.
I forgot his name.
Basically just doing short videos of like,
"Did you know that this is a real stomach?
I'm going to open it up
and show you how food is
digested," or whatever.
And he has a YouTube channel
and he literally gets a real
human body that was donated--
- Where is he getting these--?
- People donate their bodies
to science after they die.
- It's Tiktokers.
- He works in some kind of
scientific research facility--
- He's fucking Dexter or something.
- "Here's what I dug up earlier!"
- It's like the modern day Dexter.
He's not a forensics expert.
He's just a Tiktoker.
- Has anyone checked
this guy's credentials?
- Is he legit?
- He's just insane.
I'm sure if I turned up
with a body being like,
"No, no, a guy donated it."
- Yeah, some guy donated it, very kindly.
- "Officer, it was a donation."
- But basically, he
gets a proper human body
and opens up the kidneys
and explains how kidney stones form
and why they fucking hurt and stuff.
And it's like,
man, I can't imagine something that big
traveling through my dick.
- How big is it?
- Some of these are big, bro.
- Some of these can go like that.
- But you have to just hope
they break down in your kidneys.
'Cause they just can't
go through the tubes.
They use ultrasound--
Ultrasonic? Yeah, ultrasonic on your like,
kidneys to break it.
- They literally scream at
it to crumble, essentially.
(Joey yells)
(Garnt yells)
And then it shatters.
That's literally what they do, sometimes.
- It's actually the title
one audio they play.
(Joey yells)
- Get this shit out of me!
- But in worst case scenarios
where not even that works,
that it's so crystallized and so hard,
they literally go through your
penis with a pair of tweezers
to just pull it out.
(Grant groans)
- I did not need to hear this.
- I'm sorry.
- I did not need to hear that.
- Yeah, yeah, this guy.
Institute of Human Anatomy.
That's the guy. Really
cool Tiktok channel.
- Sounds legit. Let's just
hope he's not a serial killer.
- I mean, he sounds nice.
- I don't want any tweezers
going in my peepee.
I can't. I literally
can't handle hospitals or,
I just faint immediately doing anything.
- That's why I'm really
nervous to get older
because you have to do,
you know, when you hit like a certain age,
you have to do annual
colonoscopy and shit like that.
I'm just not looking forward to the day
where a camera has to go up my arse, like.
- Hospitals are pretty,
the only fear that I have,
that I think it's irrational.
I guess, is that what it counts as?
- I mean, 'cause lots of bad
stuff happen at hospitals.
- It's just like,
I know that shit's
gonna happen to my body,
I'm not used to it, I don't like it.
I don't like anything.
And I just,
I always get so lightheaded
'til I faint. It's horrible.
- You scared of needles
or anything like that?
- No, I don't give a shit about needles.
It's operations and stuff terrify me.
- It's just things entering my
body that shouldn't be there.
- Even when I went to the
dentist the other day,
just having the fucking shit in my mouth,
fucking loud as fuck.
(Joey imitates whirring)
I was getting lightheaded.
I was like, fuck.
- I mean, that's why everyone
hates going to the dentist.
'Cause you hear sounds in your mouth
that just shouldn't be made anywhere near.
- It's weird 'cause I
didn't give a fuck as a kid.
I didn't care at all when I
had to go and do that stuff.
But I dunno what happened
between after age 18
where I suddenly started
being terrified of it.
I'm not really sure why.
- I can barely give myself eyedrops,
let alone something going into my body.
- Well, sometimes you have that friend
who's had like 10 surgeries.
I'm like, how the fuck are you doing this?
How are you not fucking
freaking out all the time?
Maybe they are, I dunno.
- It's like when my dad comes back
from his annual colonoscopy, right.
It's just like, you
know, it's the same vibe
as, yeah, I just went to the pub.
- I think I legit would faint.
- Yeah, right?
- How do I tell the doctor,
listen, I'm a little bitch, bro.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
You gonna loop me up
or something? I dunno.
- I'm lucky enough to have
never needed to have surgery
or anything like that.
But just the concept of
it fucking terrifies me.
That's one thing that
fucking keeps me up at night.
- Even if it's not a
life-threatening surgery.
- The whole idea of being under anesthesia
just terrifies me.
- I hate the surgeries
where you're not on it.
Or you're on light one.
Like the surgeries when,
I think my parents,
my mum had something with a heart
and she had to be awake for it.
And that sounded terrifying.
- What?
- Yeah, because apparently, I don't know.
It sounded awful.
Apparently, you can feel it and stuff.
(Joey and Garnt groan)
- Yeah, it's terrible.
Exactly, right, it's horrible.
But if you have to have it,
you have to have it, right?
But I think maybe it came from,
I had to get,
'cause I had hemophilia where I'd like,
if I bleed, you know, don't stop bleeding.
I had to go like every three
or six months to the hospital
to go and do tests just to make
sure it wasn't getting worse
or getting any better.
Luckily it didn't get any
worse, but yeah, it was awful.
I hated going.
And it was just a terrible
experience because--
- I think it's because of
the atmosphere in a hospital.
That hospital atmosphere.
- So the ward I'd always had to go to
was just filled with old
people that were dying.
And some of them couldn't
even think or talk.
And I felt so bad 'cause
they would talk to me
and they just didn't understand.
It scared the fuck out
of me when I was like 13.
I was like, oh my God, oh Jesus.
- Because it's that glimpse
into a possible future, right?
Of like, "Oh, shit, I could
be like that one day."
- And the smell.
- Talking about smells,
hospitals do definitely
have a distinct smell.
- Even thinking about the
smell makes me uncomfortable.
- That's what I hate
about the dentist as well.
The dentist has that type
of smell that's like,
(Joey exclaims)
what is that?
- Dentists smell sanitized.
- It's like it's overly sanitized.
You know where it's
like, this is too clean.
- Yeah, it's like you just
stepped into a crime scene.
(Joey laughs)
- Everything's bleached to shit.
- Yeah, everything's bleached to shit.
- I hate it when the
doctor doesn't talk at all.
Doesn't crack jokes or anything.
I like it, 'cause when the nurse,
when the nurse is funny as fuck,
I feel so good. I feel like I'm chill.
When the nurse is cracking jokes.
She's like, "Yeah, I do
this all the fucking time."
And she's telling me about funny, old
other patients and stuff.
I feel so more at ease.
When the doctor doesn't say anything,
I'm like, what's going on?
Talk to me, what's going on?
- When the doctor doesn't
smile or anything like that.
- I'm like, whoa, what's going
on, bro? Come on, tell me.
- I know you're being
serious with your job,
but you know, help me calm
down a little bit, dude.
It's like, fucking hell.
It's like we're at a job interview.
- I remember there was only one time
I ever wanted to go to the hospital
and it was this one specific hospital
that I think I went to one time
had a GameCube right when it came out.
- What is this mythical hospital?
Why don't more hospitals do that?
- And I was like, all right.
I saw it as I was leaving,
I was like, next time I
come in, I'm gonna play it.
And then I went and someone
fucking stole the controllers.
So they had a GameCube with
no fucking controllers.
They're like Super Mario
Sunshine, Super Mario Strikers,
Super Mario Party Brawl.
They had Brawl somehow.
You couldn't even buy that game often.
- Why did they have this at a hospital?
- I think it was like,
a charity had given them or donated,
like a room where,
'cause it was like, when I was like 12.
So it was for the kids.
- Well, that makes the asshole
who stole the controllers
even worse.
- Some fucking dickhead stole
a fucking GameCube controller
from a children's hospital
that had been donated from a charity.
What? Who does that? Who does that?
- It's probably a mouth breather.
(all laugh)
- I feel like we're gonna get in trouble.
I don't know if this is
a controversial insult.
- Is it a controversial one?
- I don't even know.
- If it is, we apologize.
- I just can't take that
insult seriously anymore.
- [Navi] Apparently, it was an insult
back in the 1940s America.
- It's been around for that long?
- Jesus Christ. This is the
first I'm hearing of it.
- This is like, if I
taught you the word bussin,
you found that it was racist or something.
It's like, "Shit, I've been
saying it the whole episode."
I wanna know the motivation
of someone who steals a game
controller from a--
It was already a rare console at the time.
- Honestly, it's probably
another kid, right?
- It was probably another
kid, I imagine it was.
- Another kid who just
doesn't have a GameCube
or is wanting a GameCube.
- Or they stole a GameCube from somewhere
and forgot the controllers.
- 'Cause GameCubes, at that time,
I think were quite
expensive and they were,
I mean the games aren't
cheap 'cause it's Nintendo.
- I mean, the games still aren't cheap.
- Imagine you're rich
enough where your parents
buy you a GameCube but
not enough controllers,
so you steal it from a
kid's hospital. Like what?
- What an arsehole.
- I dunno. Really strange. Really bizarre.
Fuck that kid. I was so
excited to play fucking Brawl.
- What were you in the hospital for?
- I dunno, I was just
getting checkups, I think.
- You're like, "Mum, can we
go to the hospital, please?"
- I know I went to the hospital a lot.
I know I had a lot of, I think, injuries,
but all of them ended up
being just chill ones.
Just like, no big deal.
- Just like a bruise
or whatever.
- It's like bruise, sprains, nothing.
Luckily I just never broke bones, so.
I don't know how I got so lucky,
'cause I fucked my body up so many times.
I don't know how I got so lucky.
- It's like, "Why is
my kid so enthusiastic
to go to the hospital?"
- And also, sometimes you get like,
your parents would buy you a
sweet or something afterwards.
They'd be like, "Yeah,
you get some nice food.
Because you went to hospital."
- I thought when you said sweet,
I thought you meant like a hotel suite.
- I just bought me a suite.
- We call 'em sweets in the UK.
- Oh, okay.
If you buy chocolate or
that, it's like sweets.
- Do you know what we
call them in Australia?
Lollies.
(Garnt laughs)
- We have, if they're lollipops.
Do you refer to all candy as--?
- All candy are lollies.
- We refer to lollies as just lollipop.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But in Australia,
they're all called lollies.
There's this infamous meme
photo of me from back in the day
where I'm at an airport in Sydney.
And I just thought it was really funny.
I just posed next to
this sign that just said,
"Bagged Lollies," and I just did that.
And it's made its rounds on meme forums.
- I'm glad that the lollipop is
the worst candy of all time.
'Cause now I can say,
I hate lollies in every sense of the word.
(Joey laughs)
No, I remember when I used
to get it like age 10,
they give you a lollipop.
You're like, for fuck's sake.
It's the cola flavored fucking lollipop.
- I like the cola flavored ones.
- Fuck, that sucks, man.
- You mean the Chupa Chups, right?
- Yeah!
- The cola flavored
Chupa Chups are the best.
- No, fuck off. Cola flavored
sweets are just not good.
- They suck.
- It's like eating hard, flat Coke.
And that's the best way I can describe it.
Like flat Coke is bad enough as it is.
Let's make it hard.
- I never liked it. Who liked lollipops?
They fucking sucked.
- I mean, I'm not going to
go out of my way to eat a
fucking Chupa Chups now,
but I won't complain if
someone gives me one.
- It was made to make kids
eat sweets for a long time
that aren't actually a lot of sweets.
I was smart. I realized this is waste,
this is not optimized.
I can eat way more than this.
- I have teeth to break this down.
- I hated it. I'd never
go for the lollipops.
- What's your favorite type of candy?
Like the one that you always go back to.
- I think chocolate is
the best sweet thing,
but that's often not considered candy.
It's kind of in its own thing.
I really liked the--
- Haribo. I love Haribo.
- Sour Haribo were pretty fucking good.
I like sour Haribo. I
like the laces, you know?
- Oh, the sour strips, right?
- Oh, the sour strips,
the rainbow sour strips?
- Yeah, yeah!
- Those things slap. I love those.
- In Australia, did you
have the penny sweets?
- Penny sweets?
- Yeah, we had this in the UK.
- Yeah, where you go to a,
literally a fucking candy store
and you get given a bag
and you just fill it up.
- Oh yes, yes, yes.
- I mean those, I think those
fucking candies slapped.
- The biggest one in
Wales is in my town and
it's literally like the size of this set.
- That's huge.
- Every single wall is candy. It's good.
And they used to have these
really fucking sour things.
Like they're the most
sour sweet in the world.
They're just dunked in that
fucking horrible sour stuff
you gave us that one video.
It was just fun.
- I love sour candy, man.
- Yeah. Sour candy is my
favorite, but it's awful though,
'cause you can't drink anything afterwards
and water tastes bad.
- Water tastes sweet, right?
I kinda like that though.
- What? No.
- It's something about
that, where it's like
every other drink tastes
like absolute shit.
But when the water is
sweet, I'm just like, ooh.
That's kinda nice.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
think it's that bad.
It's fucking water. It's just water, bro.
- I think I'm too British, I
think I like crisps the most.
They're just my favorite snack.
- Walkers crisps?
- Yeah, Walkers crisps are amazing.
We have so many good crisps in the UK.
Cause it's like a national identity.
Like every single lunch must
have a bag of crisps in it.
- Not chips, crisps.
- Crisps.
- Nah, they're called chips.
- We have so many good brands of crisps.
I fucking love Monster
Munch. I love McCoy's.
- Monster Munch sounds epic.
- Dude, Monster Munch fucking slaps.
- I will say the best crisps I miss,
Walker's Max Paprika Flavor.
- That's just McCoy's
kind of, but like lighter.
McCoy's are thick.
- Nah, nah, nah. 'Cause
Walker's Max has the right--
- These must sound fucking
stupid to any Americans.
They're like, "What are they saying?"
- I'm just like, what are these?
- The Walkers Max crisps
have the right amount of
oiliness to them.
It's just like, it's a little unhealthy.
- It's kind of weird, 'cause
we give like, you know,
I don't know what the standard lunch is
in Australia or America.
But if you ever have a lunch in the UK,
it normally just comes with crisps.
It's a given that--
- Oh, like school lunch?
- Most lunches come with a bag of crisps.
- Yeah, I guess like, you know,
I used to eat chips
and stuff during lunch.
- But then it's really
common as well to just have
tons of bags of crisps
in your house in the UK.
- Yeah, we have that as well.
- Every meal deal you get
in the UK includes crisps.
Like it doesn't matter if
it's fucking Tesco's or--
- You go to Subway, there's crisps.
You go to Greg's, there's crisps.
It's always like, it comes with the lunch.
It's such a staple in
the British lifestyle.
- What, just like salt flavored or?
- No, we have so many flavors,
and I think they're amazing.
I've yet to find many
brands of crisps that
I don't like in the UK.
Like Quavers, I love Quavers.
I love, even though you have to buy--
So, Quavers, have you seen these before?
Basically cheese flavored
like thin curls of--
- Yeah, they're cheese flavored,
but they don't taste
anything like Cheetos.
- No, no, it's much lighter,
and you can eat seven bags in one sitting,
no problem, 'cause it
just tastes like air.
The whole thing is like,
it's light and has two calories
Yeah, but it has like
two bites in the bags,
so of course it's two calories.
Yeah, that's what it looks like.
They're fucking amazing, bro.
- Never seen that.
- I think those are okay.
- We have these Pom Bears.
What are they called?
They're in France as well.
- Pom Bears?
- Yeah, like the bears
crisps. They're just bears.
- I've never seen those before.
- They're really good.
- What the fuck are they?
- They're in Europe, too.
Yeah, they're German, right.
They have those there.
But the other British ones,
dude, Monster Munch is my favorite.
Chris loves Monster Munch
too, I think, and McCoy's.
He's really British, though.
- Yeah.
- McCoy's is okay.
I still stand by the Walkers Max.
- Let me Google British crisps.
There's so fucking many.
- This has been like a
fucking tangent, hasn't it?
- All Australians watching
this can agree that
the best chips we have
is Red Rock Deli chips.
That is the one brand
that I've been saying,
since the beginning of my
career, I will happily sell.
- We recently,
about at this time, before I left,
we recently started having
a boom of high-end crisps
in the UK.
- Oh, you mean the kettle chips?
- Kettle chips are the bomb.
- I do like them.
- Tyrrells are massive now in the UK.
- Tyrrells?
- They're called Tyrrells.
You sometimes see them in
Japan, they import them.
- Really?
- As like premium British crisps.
This one's in French.
They're called French Fries.
Do you have these?
- I think so.
- They're just crisps that
are shaped like french fries.
- Yeah, we have those.
- They're really fucking good.
- I don't think they're
called French Fries, though.
There's a different brand for those.
- We have Squares by Walkers as well.
- I fucking love Squares!
- Ah, Squares fucking slaps.
- Okay, now you're talking, Connor.
Now you're talking.
- Dude, they're so good.
- Squares?
- I'll put them on screen.
- I assume they're square.
- They're crispy, salty squares,
and the salt and vinegar
ones are super fucking salty.
They have salt and
vinegar, prawn cocktail,
and cheese and onion.
- Prawn cocktail?
I've realized cheese and onion
is a very British flavor.
- Is it?
- Fucking cheese and onion--
- 'Cause we don't have cheese
and onion flavored stuff
in Australia.
- Dude, you're missing out.
Cheese and onion is honestly,
I think, the best one.
- The one brand of chips that
I thought was fucking awesome
was when I was in Ireland, I had Tayto's.
- Tayto's? I think that's
a specific Irish one.
- Specific to Ireland, but
the cheese and flavor Tayto's.
Man, orgasmic. They're so fucking good.
- But, wait, fuck, what
were we on before that?
- Squares.
- Squares? Squares are really nice.
We also have Hula Hoops.
- Hula Hoops?
- Do they have these in America?
I'm pretty sure they do.
They're just the ones you put on your,
they can fit on your fingers.
They're like rings.
- Oh yeah, I know those.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We have Nik Naks. I
really like Nik Naks.
- I never had those.
That's a very like,
like marmalade coated crisps.
- Marmalade?
- Right? I think that's what it is.
Is that what it is? I
can't remember what it is.
- We have Wotsits.
- That sounds weird.
- What are they called,
Wotsits in America as well?
- I think they have Wotsits in America.
- They're like Cheetos.
- Yeah. They kinda feel like Cheetos.
- Jacob's Minis.
Sensations.
- I remember Sensations, oh my God.
- They had premium bagged crisps.
- Yeah, but these are all
Walkers brands, right?
- Yeah, they're all owned by Walkers.
- 'Cause Walkers is like,
what are they called in America, again?
Lays.
- I wish we had this
conversation last week
when Shu was here
because I don't have another
Australian to relate to.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Damn it.
- People have like,
apparently there's so
many news organizations
in the UK have done tier lists of crisps
from bottom tier to high tier.
- That's an after dark--
- It's a special.
- We also had a bag of crisps
that was really popular.
It was called Salt and Shake.
It was like a bag of crisps
that hadn't been salted,
and it would come with salt.
And the whole gimmick
of this thing was that
you put the salt in and you'd shake it.
- You'd literally salt it yourself.
- Right, right, right.
- And it tasted like shit.
- I was about to say,
that's kind of innovative.
- Because it was just unsalted evenly.
Like the salt would stick to the bottom.
- And then the rest of the
salt's just at the bottom.
- It was terrible.
If you come to the UK,
I really highly recommend
trying all our crisps.
- I don't really rate the
Japanese ones too much.
- Nah, they're pretty bad.
- The pizza potato ones are pretty good.
- I don't know why you
like the pizza potato ones.
- Yeah. I told Chris, I was like,
next video that I want to make with him
is trying all the Japanese crisps.
'Cause it was just two
super British people
complaining about crisps.
'Cause there's a lot of meh ones here.
- Most of the ones you find
here are just pretty meh.
Especially the ones from like the company.
- The flavors they have is so bizarre,
and they have Doritos here,
but they're taco flavored and
it does not taste like taco.
- Well, they have Cheetos here as well,
but it doesn't taste like Cheetos.
- But that's how I feel
about pizza flavored stuff.
I mean, what is the flavor
of pizza anyway, right?
- Crust.
- Yeah, no crust apparently.
Not a single fucking crust in sight, mate.
You won't see a crust.
- You should love it,
technically. There's no crust.
- I mean it's a pizza.
- It's a pizza!
- It's a pizza! You need
the crust in the pizza, j
just not the crust by itself.
- You hearing this?
- This man is dumb.
- I'm not going to start.
We're not gonna start talking about
fucking pizza crust again.
We've moved on. We've evolved from that.
- Let's just talk about the patrons
before we get onto that tangent.
- Talking about people
who are definitely not mouth breathers,
look at all these Patreons.
- I bet it's going to insult
so many people, oh my God.
- I really hope not.
- I really hope there isn't
a mouth breathing community
on the Internet that's
just gonna come out.
But, hey, if you're not a mouth breather,
then maybe go over to our
Patreon, patreon.com/trashtaste.
- I'll laugh if this
episode ages super horribly.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Probably fucking will.
- This becomes like the next racial slur.
But, yeah, consider
following us on Patreon
to support the show,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But, yeah.
- I'm literally Googling right now,
"Is mouth breathers offensive?"
- It doesn't matter because
the way Garnt said it
sounded a little too cozy. A little too--
- It was a hard M on the
word mouth there, Garnt.
I don't like the way you inflicted that.
- I hope you enjoyed this
episode of Trash Taste.
- We'll see you guys next week.
- It says, "Being called mouth breather
is used as a derogatory term
used to describe someone who is,
well, here's the urban
dictionary definition,
literally someone who
lacks enough intelligence
that they never learned to
breathe through their nose.
- All right, well, that's been
this episode of Trash Taste.
- And on that bombshell, good night.
- [Joey] Bye!
(gentle upbeat music)